Und jetzt ist es fertig.
Hallo Chat, ich weiß, ungewöhnliche Zeit, wobei es Feiertag ist, da ist 12.30 Uhr gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Heute gucken wir uns mal alle Linux-Desktops, also halbwegs verbreiteten Linux-Desktops
an.
Ich habe ja in letzter Zeit, bin ich ja zum KDE-Enjoyer geworden.
Dachte ich mir, vielleicht sind die anderen ja noch viel besser.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Ich glaube ja nicht, ja.
Ihr wisst, dass ich kein großer Fan der meisten Linux-Desktops bisher war.
Aber es ist ja auch schon eine ganze Weile her, wo ich das ausprobiert habe.
Ich muss aber gerade mal kurz mein...
Mein TempleOS ist keine Linux-Distribution.
Wird außerdem nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
So.
Ich werde mal einen Vorschau-Rechner anmachen.
Test.
Ja, für uns etwas großer Kek-Alu.
Big Kek-Alu.
Max, kannst du erklären, was so ein Unterschied zwischen Wayland und KDE ist?
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
KDE ist das Desktop-Environment.
und Wayland ist
die Schicht unten drunter
so wie quasi die Grafikkarte angesteuert wird
und wie Fenster gemalt werden und sowas
das heißt Wayland
gibt es auch
es gibt auch Gnome für Wayland
oder
Hyperland für Wayland
Sway für Wayland
und sonst was
Wayland ist so quasi die Abstraktionsschicht
zwischen
Betriebssystem und Desktop Environment
und KDE
ist das Desktop Environment.
Exzellent, ja.
Früher gab es X, früher gab es
X11.
Da ist Wayland jetzt die
modernere Alternative, wobei
Wayland einiges nicht kann, was X11 konnte.
Aber umgedreht ist es auch so.
wobei es halt ein bisschen den unterschied gibt zwischen x11 und wayland x11 ist nicht nur die
technologie an sich sondern auch eine implementierung und wählen ist prinzipiell
erst mal nur die technologie wo es unterschiedliche implementierung von ihm kann also egal kannst dir
merken sowohl x11 als auch weil das quasi die abstraktion schicht zwischen betriebssystem
grafik ausgabe grafikkarte und sowas und seinem desktop environment ja mit ist nicht verkehrt
mein vater verwendet auch jetzt schon seit drei jahren oder so linux mint auf mini pc seitdem hat
er keine viren mehr die er sich einfach wegen dem download scheiß oder was anderes ich habe
automatische updates eingeschaltet seitdem muss ich auch nicht mehr remote auf den rechner drauf
ihr wisst, ich habe eh das beste Verhältnis zu meinem Vater,
muss ich auch nicht mehr
remote mich einloggen da drauf und
es funktioniert einfach alles.
Also,
also, Grafiktreiber ist es
auf jeden Fall nicht.
Ja, Grafiktreiber gibt es verschiedene,
aber das ist, äh,
ich meine, es gibt ja zig verschiedene Dinger, ja.
Du hast, erstmal hast du einen Linux-Körnel,
dann hast du einen Grafikkartentreiber.
Das ist dann sowas wie, äh,
wie heißt das ding feier wie heißt der amd die amd gpu amd gpu zum beispiel ja das ist
im linux kölner ein treiber für amd grafikkarten so dann hast du sowas wie mesa zum beispiel das
ist ein bein das ist dann und noch mal oben drauf zum beispiel eine open gl implementierung oder
Oder eine Vulkan-Implementierung oder sonst was.
Und darauf, da hast du dann sowas wie Wayland.
Ich brauche Hilfe. Bald ist die Abschlussprüfung. Ich habe noch nicht gemacht.
Wie bekomme ich Motivation?
Also, wie du Motivation bekommst, das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ist es nicht Motivation genug, dass du die Prüfung packst?
Motivation, du brauchst, ohne Scheiß, man kann auch Sachen ohne Motivation machen.
Glaub mir, ich mache auch viele Sachen ohne Motivation.
Du kannst auch Sachen ohne Motivation machen, weil du logisch realisierst, dass es für dich nicht schlecht ist.
Auch wenn du keinen Bock drauf hast.
Man kann Sachen machen, ohne Bock drauf zu haben.
Du musst nicht wahnsinnig Bock drauf haben, das zu machen.
Aber am besten ist, du machst alte Abschlussprüfungen.
Da musst du am Tag eine Stunde was machen oder so, ja.
Das reicht.
Und dann machst du jeden Tag Abschlussprüfungen und dann weißt du Bescheid.
Bock hat da glaube ich auch kaum einer drauf.
Odolmet, dankeschön für den Sub-Pog-Subscription.
Nee, wenn du es nicht packst, dann darfst du die Abschlussprüfung nochmal wiederholen.
So schnell geht das nicht.
Aber du packst das.
Die Abschlussprüfung ist nicht schwierig.
Ganz ehrlich, du musst nichts können für die Abschlussprüfung.
Das Einzige, was du können musst für die Abschlussprüfung, ist alte Abschlussprüfung.
Du musst inhaltlich, du kannst inhaltlich der komplette Kack-Noob sein.
Du musst von deinem Job absolut keine Ahnung haben.
Wenn du alte Abschlussprüfung gemacht hast, packst du das.
Ich hatte gestern...
Doch, aber ich wusste gestern, ich hatte gestern irgendwie so kein Thema spontan an der Hand.
Außer C++ Flamestream, das geht immer.
Genau, zweite Abschlussprüfung kannst du nochmal machen.
Kenn ich auch, Leute.
Und ganz ehrlich, wir hatten da einen in der Berufsschulklasse.
Der hat es geschafft, also der hatte auch keine Ahnung.
Der war früher Steinmetz.
Das war sehr, sehr, also...
sage sich wie es aber mit dem habe ich mich super verstanden ja aber da hatte
von der technik damals überhaupt kein plan
der hat es geschafft 200 punkten zu schreiben in der datenbank arbeit weil
er zweimal create table geschrieben hat da hatte wirklich überhaupt keine ahnung
der ist auch durch gefallten durchgefallen bei der ersten
abschlussprüfung der hat sich nicht richtig vorbereitet da hatte keine
ahnung und dann hatte die zweite abschlussprüfung gemacht hat halt
abschlussprüfung gelernt hatte immer noch keine ahnung aber er hat sie
geschafft so die die story von ihm wie er fachinformatiker systemintegration
ausbildung gelernt hat ist auch ein bisschen tragisch der war früher
steinmetz hat er mir erzählt und da ist ihm bei der arbeit er hatte den
arbeitsunfall arbeitsunfall dem ist eine steinplatte auf den fuß gefallen nein
das war nicht der endpunkt dem ist steinplatte auf dem fuß gefallen hat sein fuß irgendwie
kaputt gemacht kann man nicht sagen aber beeinträchtigt ja dann konnte in dem beruf
nicht mehr weiter arbeiten und dann hat sein chef gesagt wo dieser arbeitsunfall passiert
ist eigentlich auch sehr ehrenhaft ja hat gesagt ich kenne da ein der hat eine firma die physis
ausbildet. Willst du nicht eine Ausbildung
als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
machen? Und so ist der
zu Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gekommen.
Also der hatte vorher auch überhaupt keinen Bezug dazu.
Hast du schon mal Komodo versucht?
Du meinst dieses
Docker Frontend? Ja.
Hab ich.
Ganz kurz.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz. Gibt's den eigentlich noch?
Der streamt manchmal
Arma, hab ich gesehen. Oder hat früher mal Arma
gestreamt in diesem video nur ganz kurz habe ich ausprobiert ich fand es nicht
so geil das problem ist ich kann dir nicht mal genau sagen warum
Weißt du noch, ob er als Fisi arbeitet?
Ob er noch als Fisi, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe lange nichts mehr gehört von ihm.
Was sind denn die Kriterien für das heutige Thema?
Das ist ganz einfach.
Ich installiere einen Linux mit dem jeweiligen Desktop.
Also wir probieren so die üblichen Verdächtigen aus.
Hier Cosmic, Cinnamon, bei Cinnamon Kelly eigentlich ganz brauchbar.
Gnome, XFCE.
Und dann klicke ich da ein bisschen rum und gucke mir das, keine Ahnung, 25 Minuten an.
Und entscheide aus dem Bauch raus, ob mir das gefällt oder nicht.
Das Problem ist
So Sachen wie Hyperland und Sway
Können wir nicht richtig ausprobieren
Das liegt daran
Dass Wayland suckt
Und nicht in der VM ordentlich funktioniert
Und außerdem
Nachdem ich jetzt KDE Enjoyer geworden bin
muss ich ehrlich sagen ich sehe kaum nachteile von kde gegenüber meinem i3 wm setup und warum
soll ich mich da noch mit teiling window manager rumschlagen wenn man das aller aller meiste mit
kde genauso gut abfackeln kann weil ich meine was mache ich im teiling window manager ich schalte
verschiedene desktops durch mit shortcuts und ich habe auf dem ersten
desktop browser empfohlen sich genau im zweiten desktop termin im fullscreen auf
dem dritten desktop editor idee beziehungsweise dritten deshalb editor
idee vielleicht auch ein terminal so das kann ich alles easy mit kd auch machen
deswegen gucken wir uns heute wirklich nur desktops an und ganz ganz wichtig
das korrekt kde hat wobbly windows das ist in der tat das mit abstand
wichtigste das habe ich jetzt ganz vergessen zu erwähnen wo wir gerade
dabei sind ich mache mal ein mini pc wobei brauche ich den heute bin jetzt
gerade unschlüssig brauche ich den überhaupt weil wir totalisieren auf der
kiste können wir das nicht das von selbst körper vergesst das ding an 8 g
gramm ich muss unbedingt mal noch einen zweiten
zweiten 8 g kriegel bestellen 8 gb non etc ddr5 es odin ist ja das kann man sich
das geht noch 8 gig ist noch nicht so teuer das kostet 120 euro oder so oder 60 euro oder ich
weiß es nicht aber 8 gig ist jetzt nicht so wild ich muss updates ist das richtig updates arch
by the way das muss ich machen ganz wichtig ja solos mit bachi ja das ist das genau diesen mist
probier mal alles aus, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es Mist ist.
Also,
entweder
installieren wir uns quasi
die jeweilige
Main-Distro für den Desktop
oder ich installiere mir CacheOS,
mach einen Snapshot
im Installer
und wähle dann einfach den jeweiligen Desktop aus.
Ich glaube, das ist das Einfachste.
So.
Zack.
Zack, da sind wir. So laden wir uns erstmal. Cache.us Download. Desktop Edition. Direct
Download. Sourceforge mach ich nicht. Sourceforge suckt einfach nur richtig hart.
Kennt die Story überhaupt noch jeder?
Der scheiß Gnorm
Das ist schon
Das habe ich schon lange nicht mehr erzählt
Die erzähle ich dann
Wenn wir den Gnorm ausprobieren
Okay, mir läuft die Nase.
Ich war Rennen, heute 7,02 Kilometer, also 7 Kilometer.
Sehr zackig, 5,45.
Das ist so den Pace, den ich aktuell, ich hab's ja echt schleifen lassen, ja, mit Ausdauer.
5,45, so ungefähr im Durchschnitt pro Kilometer.
das ist das, was ich rennen kann,
wo es so gerade, gerade
noch angenehm
genug ist.
Alles andere, alles drüber ist anstrengend.
Okay, dann erzähl ich das mal kurz. Also,
ich hatte mal einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit, auf der alten Arbeit,
der war irgendwie
ein bisschen merkwürdig und zwar,
der hatte sein Linux installiert
auf dem Notebook und er hat
seinen Desktop so eingerichtet. Also ich
weiß nicht mal, wie man das
macht, Leute. Aber da hat
sein Desktop so eingestellt,
dass wenn er
mit der Maus
an den Rand gekommen ist vom
Bildschirm, dann hat sein PC
Speaker gemacht.
So.
Also wie gesagt, ich wüsste, wenn
einer zu mir sagt, Max,
stell mal deinen Desktop so ein,
dass dein PC Speaker summt, wenn
du mit der Maus an den Rand kommst.
Ich wüsste nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ich hätte absolut kein
Plastenschimmer, wie ich das überhaupt machen sollte.
Und ab und zu ist das,
vielleicht hat er das gemacht, dass wenn er einschläft,
wisst ihr, er schläft so ein,
ich schlaf ein,
weil zumindest,
wenn er das,
wenn das passiert ist,
dann hat er immer, das lief dann so,
dann hat es, irgendwann hat es
sein PC-Speaker gemacht,
und danach hat er gesagt, der Scheiß-Knomb.
So als wäre das
Als wäre das die Fall Setting
Vom Gnome Desktop gewesen
Ich meine wer kennt es nicht
PC Speaker geht an wenn du mit der Maus den Bildschirmrand berührst
Bzzzt
Der scheiß Gnome
Der Kerl war eh lustig irgendwie
Was hältst du grundsätzlich von Cosmic
Ich habe Cosmic noch nie ausprobiert
Das machen wir heute.
Weiß ich nicht.
Kann ich mir aber tatsächlich vorstellen.
Chip macht sowas gerne.
Chip ist dann, wenn du bei denen downloadest,
dann musst du den unteren Download-Link nehmen,
weil der obere diesen komischen Chip-Downloader enthält
und sowas. Ganz, ganz
abenteuerlich.
Chat, ich bin gerade etwas verwirrt.
wenn ich auf dem zweiten ich muss noch dritten desktop machen für die vm weil
weil ich habe jetzt hier windows da linux mini pc und da jetzt vm das wird
zu viel zeug so kann man das ding hier zweck fremden display accelerate 3d
graphics advanced uefi und prozessor namen auf kurs 4 kommt scheiß drauf 5 und 16 g
rahmen so das sollte eigentlich reichen
desktop
cosmic kann man on demand zwischen floating und teiling da kann man kommen
wir fangen mit kosmik an wenn wir kosmik installieren soll man dann gleich popo es
auch installieren oder kann man das auch unter cash ganz gut ausprobieren
ja okay pop us download wir hatten pop us schon mal ausprobiert vor ganz langer
zeit da gab es glaube ich diesen desktop da noch nicht okay 24 04 lts basiert das
etwa auf wo habe ich wo habe ich es moment moment moment passiert das etwa
auf.
Okay.
Ja, dann.
Including
Telio Astra.
Soll man wissen,
was Telio Astra ist?
Was ist Telio Astra?
das ist helio astra der first official desktop stream selbstfahrende auto entwicklung entwicklung
für selbstfahrende auto was zum ok damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet
Popo es genau aber okay whatever
downloaden wir das mal sagt
accept
später
starte das verdammte Spiel
58 Sekunden
okay, top, Horgel
so, gehen wir mal hier hin
gehen wir da hin, müssen wir Chatterino noch starten
das wird heute kompliziert
das verwirrt mich bestimmt
dass ich jetzt auf einmal 3 Desktops habe
anstatt 2
ist Cosmic nicht auch bei der Desktop Auswahl
bei Cachy dabei? Doch
Aber der Chat meint, wir müssen Popo S ausprobieren.
als dringender exe ich kann halt mal endlich ausprobieren weil es nicht in der form funks
ich habe auch echt kein interesse mehr an halpern ich könnte ich hätte es mir ja hier
auf meinem mini pc installieren können aber ich bin jetzt richtig kde enjoyer geworden deswegen
also ich hab's als ich habe auch an zwei und so kein großartiges interesse mehr den einzigen
teilen wir noch mal den ich irgendwie ganz cool fand nicht mongo mango nicht mongol wm mango wm
also wie ich zwar von videos gesehen habe den wollte ich mal ausprobieren aber selbst da habe
ich jetzt kein interesse mehr dran den auszuprobieren weil ich wie gesagt ich kann
mit kde quasi zu zu 98 prozent genau das machen wofür ich früher treiben teil
links setup verwendet habe bloß halt alles andere was kde noch so kann ich
habe da eigentlich ich habe wirklich das interesse so ein bisschen an teiligen
wenn man schon verloren da ist der katze auf dem desktop ja dann das wäre
natürlich schon ein argument ja so ist popo es runtergeladen ja dann moment
jetzt muss ich erst mal gucken dass ich durchblicke das gehen wir dahin sagen
hier cd laufwerk iso image download opf
Achso, gab hier eben noch eine
Question im Chat, habe ich gar nicht gesehen
Irgendwas
Max, kannst du das Prinzip
der Serverkonsolidierung
erklären?
Ja, also
ich kann es dir keine
IHK gerechte Definition
für eine Abschlussprüfung liefern, aber
für mich
heißt das sowas wie
seine Hardware halt möglichst gut auslasten,
dass man mit weniger Hardware auskommt.
Ja, also zum Beispiel
anstatt
zwei Debian-Kisten zu betreiben
auf Bare Metal, die vor sich hin
eideln, kann man einfach das
auf einer Kiste machen und
darauf zwei VMs laufen lassen.
So, das verstehe ich unter Server-Konsolidierung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das bei der
Abschlussprüfung damit gemeint ist oder
ob das die richtige Definition
ist. Keine Ahnung.
Aber das würde ich jetzt da drunter verstehen.
Wisst ihr, was ich witzig fand?
Ich habe das letzte Linus-Techtipps-Video so ein bisschen übersprungen, wo es darum ging, er versucht mal wieder Linux.
Wisst ihr, was ich daran witzig fand?
Da haben die so eine Übersicht gebracht von Distributionen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was sie da zur Auswahl hatten.
Pop OS, Fedora und sonst was.
Was ich witzig fand ist, dass sie selbst in dem Video sagen, sie haben keine Ahnung von Linux, aber bringen dann eine Distributionsübersicht, was wie für was gut ist.
Wie willst du das machen, wenn du keine Ahnung hast?
Das war schon merkwürdig.
Linux nur für echte ITler rentabel oder auch für Normies?
Es kommt immer darauf an, was du machen willst.
Also ganz ehrlich, so beschissen wie Windows 11 mittlerweile ist, wenn man ein bisschen lernbereit ist, solltest du für die meisten Sachen überhaupt keine Probleme mehr haben, mittlerweile mit sowas wie Linux Mint oder meinetwegen auch einem Fedora mit KDE oder einem CacheOS mit KDE klar zu kommen.
Du brauchst ein bisschen Lernbereitschaft, du musst das ungefähr so sehen, wie wenn du das erste Mal vor einem Windows-Rechner gesessen hast, da wusstest du ja auch nichts, du musst ein bisschen was lesen, ein bisschen was gezeigt kriegen und sonst was.
Damit kommst du klar, es gibt mittlerweile auch sehr viele Noobs, die Linux verwenden, das funktioniert.
Du musst dir aber ein bisschen überlegen, was du genau machen willst. Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel den Anspruch hast, du willst dir sicher sein, dass die neuesten Games auch auf jeden Fall laufen oder du willst, dass Games mit Kernel-Level-Anti-Cheat spielen, dann hast du wahrscheinlich Schwierigkeiten, das unter Linux zu machen.
Wobei man ja mal der Fairness halber sagen muss, viele der neuen Games laufen ja, selbst wenn sie rauskommen, auch unter Windows nicht richtig.
Das ist ja gut, aber ihr wisst, wie ich es meine.
Das nächste ist, falls du einen speziellen Anspruch hast an Adobe Software und sowas.
Oder spezielle Software, die halt wirklich nur gescheit unter Windows läuft.
Es wird immer weniger, aber gibt es immer noch genug, dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch nichts.
Für alles andere, ja, lohnt es sich meiner Meinung nach mal zu gucken, ob man mit Linux auskommt.
Ich persönlich mache das so, Saitaros, ich mache das so.
Ich habe hier mein Windows, das ich benutze ich für Streaming, Gaming, Videos schneiden und Thumbnails erstellen und sowas.
und dann habe ich hier eine linux mini pc die hier beelink sr 7 ist das also es ist auch kein super
krassteurer mini pc mit einem acht kern reisen also der hat schon cpu leistungs mit ein bisschen
wumms einem acht kern reisen und darauf habe ich cash us mit kde installiert das heißt ich habe ein
vollwertiges linux bare metal auf gaming pc mit 64 gramm weil das ja eigentlich
wie scheiße teuer das heute gewesen wäre 64 g gramm 40 90 rtx wasserkühlung also
richtig richtig fette desktop kiste und linux habe ich mini pc mit amd gpu amd
cpu und sonst was da habe ich für mich das beste aus beiden welten ich habe
metal windows der metal linux so eingerichtet dass ich sie dazwischen umschalten kann und benutzt
einfach jeweils die betriebssysteme dafür wo ich ihre stärken sehe ja ich mache quasi das
allermeiste also wenn wir hier im stream sind ja im stream sind wir zu 90 prozent unter linux
unterwegs privat bin ich eher so war sag mal 40 60 40 prozent unter windows 60 prozent unter linux
Das ist für mich das beste Setup.
Was du auch machen kannst ist, wenn du dir noch nicht sicher bist, ob du mit Linux klarkommst, installierst dir mal in AVM.
Probier mal beispielsweise CacheOS in AVM aus.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, Performance-mäßig ist das ohne Probleme zu benutzen.
ja aber es fühlt sich doch eine ganze ecke nicer an auf der echten hardware
gerade weil weil er in der vm so viele probleme macht aber kannst du ausprobieren
so dass man kurz gucken
bietet es für dich einzigartig also du kannst linux was heißt du kannst an
An manchen Stellen, wenn mal was irgendwie nicht funktioniert, musst du sogar, aber du kannst Linux deutlich besser konfigurieren als Windows.
Du kannst ja unter Windows mittlerweile so gut wie nichts mehr ändern.
Du kannst, ich glaube, du kannst die Taskleiste noch nicht mal mehr gescheit verschieben an den linken Rand oder sowas.
Du kannst ja hier eigentlich, bis auf ein paar Farbtöne, kannst du ja nichts mehr einstellen.
Also das geht unter Linux tatsächlich deutlich besser.
Aber man muss aber sagen, so Distributionen wie Cache.us, also das, was ich hier gerade auf habe, das kommt auch schon ganz sinnvoll vorkonfiguriert hier.
Und, Moment, wie hieß der?
Cytaros, du hast eine Sache unter Linux, die hast du unter Windows nicht und die wirst du unter Windows auch nicht haben.
Das ist für mich das wichtigste Feature, das es gibt.
Und zwar, halt dich fest, sowas Geiles hast du noch nie gesehen.
wobbly windows.
Ist das nicht geil?
Guck mal. Also spätestens jetzt
müsstest du eigentlich komplett davon überzeugt sein,
CacheUS mit KDE mal zu installieren.
Ist das nicht pock?
Wobbelnde Fenster. Übrigens,
das, was so ruckelt im Stream, liegt daran,
der Stream ist
ähm,
der Stream ist 48 FPS
und
Der Stream ist 48 FPS
Und mein Desktop ist 240 Hertz
Also bei mir ist das butterweich
Das Gewobbel
Im Stream ist es ein bisschen ruckelig
Vielleicht, ja
Aber das ist ohne Scheiß das beste Feature überhaupt
Guck mal, das wobbelt sogar beim Resizen
Siehst du das?
Du kannst sogar wobbly resizen
Chat, Sekunde, ich brauch das passende Emote.
Listening.
Listening Emote.
Okay, genug gelistet.
Was ist der Grund für 48 FPS?
Du meinst, warum mein Stream mit 48 FPS läuft?
Das liegt daran,
weil wir in Deutschland
oder weil viele in Deutschland
semi-gutes Internet haben.
Und 48fps bietet für meine Begriffe die optimale Kombination aus Flüssigkeit und Bandbreite.
Das heißt 1080p at 60fps wäre vielleicht minimal flüssiger, braucht aber auch mehr
Bandbreite, deswegen 48fps.
das kommt ist gefühlt beim zugucken
ähnlich flüssig wie 60 FPS
braucht aber eine Ecke weniger Bandbreite
und so können auch Leute von Mobile ordentlich gucken oder
eben wenn sie nur
im geschehen gescherten Internetanschluss haben ganz viel
Familienmitglieder und Scheiße Internetanschluss haben
man darf den 3D Desktop Würfel nicht vergessen stimmt
ganz wichtig
Moment
die Facts
dem muss ja auch noch zeigen
dass du noch mehr überzeugt bist cashier erstmal ausprobieren auszuprobieren cube
cube wichtig meter c komm mal hier
du kannst deinen unterschiedlichen desktops kannst du auf den würfel
packen und dann durch scrollen ich habe vier
desktops und mit vier desktops ich gebe aber zu das ist keine keine wirklich
sinnvolle funktion bin ich finde ich das ist das ist eine reine show reine show
funktion um zu zeigen wie geil es ist ja ich mache sie mich auch wieder aus oder
oder chat chat chat benutzt dass jemand von euch wirklich daily die würfel
funktion
warum so eine krumme zahl wie 48 fps ja habe ich ja gerade erklärt übrigens 48
fps ist gar nicht so ob es habe ich da so fahrt der hobbit wurde auch nach 40
fps gedreht sagt aber macht ja auch nicht zum besseren film oder besseren
filme
Ich habe auch alle Desktop-Effekte deaktiviert.
Guck mal.
Also, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe nicht alle Desktop-Effekte aktiviert.
Ich habe einen Desktop-Effekt deaktiviert.
Und das ist Wobbly Windows.
Weil Wobbly Windows ist einfach der beste Effekt.
Den habe ich schon zu Compets-Zeiten immer benutzt.
Aber ansonsten habe ich auch alle Desktop-Effekte deaktiviert.
Guck, ich habe nichts mehr, wenn das Fenster aufgeht.
Ich habe nichts mehr, wenn das Fenster zugeht.
Ich habe keine Animationen, wenn ich die Desktops durchswitche.
Nichts mehr.
Ja gut, das Gehirn versteht nur 48 FPS.
Gut, das ist ganz klar.
Das liegt daran, ein Auge 12 FPS, zwei Augen 24 FPS und wenn man sie auf den Kopf stellt, 48 FPS.
Obviously.
Compits war Peak Linux Desktop, ich sag's euch.
Die Effekte bei KDE sind geil, aber so geil wie bei Compits waren die noch nie.
Oder kann man bei KDE...
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Oder kann man bei KDE etwa das Fenster abbrennen lassen?
Geht das?
Fire?
Ne, siehste?
Aber vielleicht hier neue Effekte.
Fire.
Burn my windows.
Ja, okay, guckt hier.
Den Feuereffekt, den gab es früher eingebaut bei Compets.
Kannst dein Fenster abbrennen lassen.
Warum haben die eigentlich alle so schlechte Bewertungen?
Kann das sein, dass 2,...
2,5 irgendwie die Default-Bewertung ist oder so?
Sort by Rating. Bam.
Es gibt auch nicht so viele Effekte.
Aber so sieht es aus
Exzellent
stimmt steuersoftware ist wohl auch ein problem aber da gibt es auch mittlerweile bestimmt
gescheite online-services oder so eins will ich aber noch abschließend zu der geschichte sagen
auf linux umsteigen oder mal linux ausprobieren man darf da nicht damit rangehen da habe ich auch
übrigens mein eigenes video zu gemacht also ich schon ein paar ist schon ein bisschen her ich
weiß letztes video ist schon eine weile her aber ich habe zu dem thema auch mal
ein video gemacht und zwar man darf nicht damit rangehen so nach dem motto
ich finde windows scheiße was man übrigens zu recht scheiße finden kann ich
finde wir uns auch scheiße sowohl windows server also windows desktop
finde ich beides scheiße aber man darf nicht damit rangehen und sagen ich finde
windows scheiße deswegen installiere ich mir jetzt linux
und das wird dann wie windows nur ohne die probleme von windows das wird nicht
funktionieren man muss damit rangehen das ist was neues nicht das essen windows ohne die probleme von windows weil es ist kein windows
das wird man auch relativ schnell merken wenn man damit rangeht also man darf nicht man darf das nicht als
es behebt alle probleme die ich mit windows haben der rest bleibt gleich sehen
Okay, jetzt mache ich erst noch mal hier betriebssystem update warum weil ich sage es ja immer wenn mein betriebssystem
älter als ein viertel stunde ist ist mir das nicht bleeding edge genug das müssen wir gleich hier fixen
keine jetbrain updates ok
so jetzt haben wir geupdatet sehr gut exzellent dann können wir hier mal auf die vm schalten und
pop os starten hoffentlich wir booten von sata cd rom oder auch nicht dass aus irgendwelchen
gründen nicht eingeschaltet guten wert von sata cd rom ja machen wir drei install popo es also pop
os sage ich euch gleich das mache ich jetzt nur für kosmic weil das angeblich die beste cosmic
Experience ist.
Was sind die drei Wellen
in deinem Sist Trail?
Ah, du meinst, ähm,
das da?
Das da?
Oh, warte mal.
Ah.
Leute, ich hab mich
verdrückt. MonkaS.
So. Ähm.
Du.
Das ist zu viel, zu viele Desktops.
Du meinst das hier, ne?
das ist was reboot recommended okay das ist deskflow damit mache ich maus und
keyboard sharing zwischen zwischen windows und linux guck hier hier habe
ich auch laufen auf windows guck da das ist ein synergy fork das macht maus und
tastatur sharing wenn ich jetzt quasi hier von linux soll ich wenn ich jetzt
hier von windows auf linux switche dann hast du sie eben auch gesehen guckt dann
schaltet das um.
Ich bin nur in dem Alter,
wo es jetzt oder nie auf Linux...
Ach, Quatsch.
Das ist doch auch nur eine Zahl im Endeffekt.
Solange man dafür offen ist,
im Kopf, ganz ehrlich, guck mal.
Ich bin jetzt auch
fast 42.
Und mir macht es immer noch Spaß,
neuen Bastelkram auszuprobieren.
Ja gut, die meisten Leute, die das nicht täglich machen sollten, angespannt sein, wenn sie
im BIOS sind.
Übrigens, was du auch machen kannst ist, also was ich empfehlen würde ist, wenn du
noch gar keinen Kontakt damit hattest, installierst du in der VM.
VMware Workstation kostet mittlerweile nichts mehr.
Also quasi der gleiche Weg, wie ich hier jetzt auch gerade Pop!
OS installiere.
Guck, ich habe das hier in VMware Workstation unter Windows laufen.
Da kann man das einfach ausprobieren.
so was du auch machen kannst wenn du es wirklich auf einem auf hardware installieren willst und
du willst ein fallback haben hast du dir schon mal überlegt zweite ssd einzubauen für linux also
mal angenommen bei meinem mini pc hier ja auf dem ich jetzt hier gerade bin da habe ich zwei ssds
drin ach so ich sollte vielleicht gut sein man sieht sie auch hier guckt ich habe zwei ssds
trainer so sieht das unter linux aus und auf der ersten ssd habe ich linux installiert zum streamen
und auf der zweiten ssd habe ich den linux installiert für mich privat so dass das dass
ich das nicht vermischen das kannst du genauso machen mit auf der ersten ssd installiert und
Und in Windows auf der zweiten SSD installierst du in Linux.
Dann hast du auch nicht das Problem wie bei Dual Boot, dass du irgendwie einen Bootmanager rumfuddeln musst oder sowas.
Du kannst sogar in BIOS einfach die erste SSD komplett deaktivieren.
Linux installieren und wenn du mal zurück in Windows willst, aktivierst du die und deaktivierst die andere.
Also man kann sich da schon so Brücken bauen.
Ansonsten, was auch noch eine gute Empfehlung ist, kauf dir einen günstigen Mini-PC.
Ja, ich hab den hier.
Da gibt es mittlerweile, gibt es aber schon
neuere und günstigere
vor allem.
Muss mal gucken, was
die für Mini-PCs haben.
Kauf dir einen günstigen Mini-PC, so
300, 400 Euro vielleicht
und installier da drauf
Windows. Äh, nicht Windows, Schwachsinn.
Und installier da drauf Linux.
Dann hast du eine eigene Kiste,
auf der du rumwurschteln kannst.
Ist auch nicht verkehrt. Also siehst du,
Es gibt sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Du kannst dir eine raussuchen.
Vielleicht brauche ich mal ein kleines System, an dem ich lernen und probieren kann.
Ja, genau.
Genau so würde ich auch machen.
Du kaufst dir entweder einen Mini-PC.
Oder du installierst dir mal rein zum Antesten das in der VM.
Mini-PC ist wahrscheinlich die einfachste Variante.
Da bist du ja komplett unabhängig von deiner Windows-Kiste.
Das CPU-Widget habe ich auch.
Das klappt aus, wenn man drauf geht?
Nö. Ach doch!
Ha! Tatsächlich!
Moment, das muss ich mal überprüfen.
Tatsächlich, man kann das ausklappen.
Chat, wusstet ihr das?
Das ist ja cool.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen,
wirklich jetzt irgendwie großartig mehr Infos
hat man ja da auch nicht.
Ob das so gedacht ist, dass man das vergrößern kann?
Ja, ist es.
Ups. Oh ne.
Guck mal, jetzt hat Wayland gebackt.
Ah gut, aber relativ useless, das auszuklappen.
Okay, zack, auf geht's.
Ist es nicht besser, echte Hardware zu verwenden?
Doch, ist es.
Ich habe aber keine echte Hardware mehr übrig.
Wobei, Chat?
Ich meine, ich habe drei Nasse hier.
Theoretisch könnte man das auf dem Nass...
Aber die Dinger, also die Nasses, die ich hier noch frei habe,
Die sind, ja, das ist nicht die geilste GPU.
Ne, wir installieren das in der VM.
Da kann ich auch Snapshot restoren.
Ne, ne, da kann ich Snapshot restoren.
Solange es nicht Hyperland ist oder irgendwas Tiling Window Manager mäßiges Wayland basiert ist, dann läuft das in der VM ganz brauchbar.
Das machen wir heute in der VM.
Okay, PopOS.
Wir installieren das Ganze in Englisch.
Botswana
Englisch
Das ist jetzt auch so ein Mini-Test
Ob mir PopOS prinzipiell
Gefällt oder nicht
Keyboard-Layout
German
Das finde ich schon mal blöd
Dass man das hier nicht eingeben kann
German, no dead keys
Seht ihr es irgendwo?
No dead keys, beste
Clean Install
Oh, meine Festplatte ist nur 8 GB
Das reicht nicht
Costume könnte Probleme in AVM haben
Okay, werden wir gleich sehen
Ist zu klein
Dann
Die kann man nicht resizen, oder?
Man muss die
Ja, dann machen wir das weg
neue neue harddisk jawohl jawohl 32 gig single file yep clock ok gut
ach jetzt muss ich wieder cd laufwerk dran machen zack 3 pop os
Also ganz ehrlich, drei PCs managen hier mit Shortcuts ist nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Welche Software nimmst du jetzt eigentlich für dein NAS?
Open Media Vault oder TrueNAS?
Ähm, Proxmox?
Und darauf wahrscheinlich ein Open Media Vault vor allem.
Weil TrueNAS kann ich nicht so verwenden, wie ich Open Media Vault verwende.
Open Media Vault benutze ich ja nur zum Managen von...
...von Shares im Endeffekt, ja?
Und TrueNAS will ja auch die Disks unten drunter managen.
Und die Disks unten drunter, die sind ja von Proxmox mit ZFS gemanagt.
Open Media Vault.
Vielleicht, ganz ehrlich, vielleicht lasse ich es auch bei dem LXC-Container mit dem Samba-Server drauf und lasse das mit Open Media Vault.
Mal gucken.
haben ein hauptsystem erst einmal das screen terminal für konsolenverbindung für mein
system durfte dann lief groß der früher hat man da mini kommt für verwendet für
konsolenverbindung weiß ich was man da was verwendet man da heute dafür für diese
serielle verbindung zu switches will sie dann auch da auch deine container vor
amsterdorf lassen auf box ja ja ja dass das was ich jetzt auf meiner hp micro
server kiste drauf habe will ich alles auf dem nass laufen lassen
Okay, Englisch, United States, Keyboard Layout, German, No Dead Keys, Clean Install, reichen 32 Gig? Jawohl.
Erase and Install. Den Installer finde ich tatsächlich schon mal ganz nice.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, highly komplexes Passwort.
encryption password ist das user account password was die machen der macht
standardmäßig drive encryption das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice
er verschüttet das heimatverzeichnis oder verschlüsselt er das komplette
die komplette disk wenn man dann gleich sehen
was heißt das du meinst es mit dem verschlüsseln hier oder was also wenn du wenn du eine voll
verschlüsselung hast dann musst du beim guten das passwort eingeben von der verschlüsselung
also du kannst dir dann zum beispiel du denkst dir dann irgendwie ein passwort aus 20 stellen
oder so und dann musst du beim guten das passwort eingeben noch bevor das betriebssystem startet das
ist nicht so wie bei windows mit beim login passwort also das boot nicht ohne
das passwort da muss das passwort eingeben und dann wird es entweder das
quasi für die restliche laufzeit des rechners entschlüsselt das kann ich auch
jedem nur empfehlen weil es hat einen riesen vorteil sein system voll
verschlüsselt zu haben von irgendwelchen kek alu geschichten die
polizei steht vor der tür mal dass wer da bedenken hat soll es auch
verschlüsselt aber das ist nicht mal nicht mal der hauptgedanke dahinter
Systeme zu verschlüsseln.
Ich finde das einfach von der Handhabung her sehr praktisch,
wenn das System verschlüsselt ist.
Weil, stell dir mal vor,
du willst irgendwas wegschmeißen von deinem Rechner.
Ja, die SSD oder die Festplatte.
Du musst immer genau gucken,
dass du alles korrekt zerstörst
oder korrekt löschst, bevor du es wegschmeißt.
Problematisch wird das Ganze natürlich,
wenn deine Festplatte nicht mehr richtig lesbar ist
und du die nicht einfach überschreiben kannst.
dann wirfst du quasi deine kompletten Daten in den Mülleimer, von dem mit Sicherheit einiges restorebar wäre.
Wird es irgendjemand restoren? Wird es irgendjemand probieren?
Höchstwahrscheinlich zu 99% nicht.
Aber ich finde den Workflow von, ich schmeiße meine Daten in den Mülleimer und jeder kann sie sich angucken, doof.
Deswegen finde ich standardmäßig Vollverschlüsselung sehr sinnvoll.
Genauso wie ich es sehr sinnvoll finde, wenn man jetzt hier gerade bei solchen Sachen sind, wenn man Access Points hat, die DPSK unterstützen. DPSK heißt, für das gleiche WLAN kann man pro Gerät unterschiedliche WLAN-Passwörter vergeben.
Und das ist nicht wie WPA Enterprise, was das Gerät unterstützen müsste, das ist transparent für das Gerät.
Das heißt MPSK, DPSK, die Hersteller nennen das ein bisschen anders.
Und da kannst du zum Beispiel für ein IoT-Gerät, kannst du ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort vergeben.
Und wenn du das IoT-Gerät, weil es kaputt ist, weil es scheiße ist, weil du es nicht mehr haben willst, in den Mülleimer schmeißt,
löscht einfach das Gerät aus deinem WLAN-Accesspoint und egal, was irgendjemand mit deinem IoT-Gerät aus dem Mülleimer anstellt,
selbst wenn da jemand super scharf drauf ist, dein WLAN-Passwort rauszubekommen und das vom Flash aus der Glühbirne extrahiert,
kann er nichts damit anfangen, weil du es schon rausgeschmissen hast.
Also das kann ich nur empfehlen, wenn man ein bisschen teurere Access Points sich anschaffen will, dass die DPSK können.
Unify kann es mittlerweile.
Aber es war der Grund, also eines der Gründe, warum ich Unify damals abgeschafft habe, weil die es jahrelang nicht hinbekommen haben, dieses Feature einzubauen.
Zu Zeiten, wo es jeder andere, bisschen größere Hersteller schon konnte.
Ob es die Fritzbox kann, bin ich mir übrigens nicht sicher.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Fritzbox das kann.
Zumindest nicht ohne Addons und Plugins und alles.
Aber wie gesagt, die Fritzbox ist ja auch kein...
...reines Modem, kein reiner Router, kein reiner Access Point,
sondern so ein Hybridgerät, was alles kann und dafür ist sie gut.
Äh, PopOS?
Chat?
Ah.
Unlock?
Okay.
Ich hab Unlocked.
Passt.
Also PropOS, eine Sache, die mir schon mal nicht gefällt,
ist, es installiert keine VMware-Tools.
Wenn keine VMware-Tools installiert werden, ist doof.
Dann sieht es in der VM so aus.
Was ist das jetzt?
Screenreader.
Ich brauch...
Was?
Das funktioniert ja richtig gut.
ich glaube wir brauchen kein screen reader auf
erste mal muss ich jetzt gucken wie man vor allem also ab search open vm
schreibt man das vm tools irgendwie so eine tools vm minus tools open vm tools desktop
weil ansonsten haben ja gar keinen gar kein ordentliches fenster hier
system ctl restart open m tools ok das schon mal schlecht
das schon mal schlecht wenn cosmic
wenn cosmic kein fullscreen kann
das geht ich meine ich könnte hier ich könnte hier natürlich einstellen
Ja, also es wird funktionieren.
Reboot, gute Idee.
Was sind vor allem mal Tools?
Okay, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Nee, hat nicht funktioniert.
Das ist, wenn man...
Äh.
Chatge?
Das ist, wenn man vor allem
eine Workstation benutzt, um seinen Linux zu
virtualisieren, dass die VM
mit dem Host kommunizieren kann. Dadurch werden
manche Sachen schneller. Und die Display-Auflösung
stimmt dann besser.
Das muss man sich nur damit auseinandersetzen,
wenn man vor allem eine Workstation verwendet.
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Was ist das?
Okay, das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Session.
Kosmik.
Alter!
Geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
Wifi aus.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Next.
Select language.
Keyboard.
Die hatte man doch schon immer.
Gerade.
German.
Kann ich nach No?
no dead key kann man nicht suchen was natürlich doch extra location okay
berlin guck mal microsoft microsoft guckt euch das mal ab und set up wo man
auch versuchen kann ordentlich drin cosmic dark cosmic light cosmic cosmic
Nebot und... Ne.
Ganz ehrlich, Cosmic Dark.
Panel Bottom.
Top Panel.
Bottom Panel.
Hmm.
Lassen wir mal default.
Workspace is for your workflow.
Das check ich nicht.
Was willst du von mir?
Äh.
Okay.
What?
Shift super.
Aha.
da kann man so ein bisschen bisschen teilen ja eigentlich ganz cool so next
fast and efficient press super auf windows to activate launcher okay finde
ich gut finish was ist der unterschied zwischen
workspaces und desktops ich würde vermuten das ist genau das
gleiche virtuelle desktop workspace ist nur dass sie es hier workspaces nennen
würde ich jetzt würde jetzt einfach mal vermuten sowie stellt man das noch mal
eine wichtige sache für mich wie stelle ich den maus cursor um aus weil ein
schwarzer mauszeiger bei einem dunklen desktop ist jetzt nicht so
Wie kann man den Cursor denn hier umstellen? Kann man das überhaupt?
Maus Acceleration, geh mal bloß weg.
Cursor, kann man den Cursor umstellen?
Cursor.
Cursor. Nö. Geht nicht.
wenn man das team ändert ändert sich dann auch der maus cursor
naja
kann man maus tastatur umstellen screen wieder
Invert Colors.
Wow.
Aber wenigstens ist mein Maus Cursor jetzt weiß.
Was ist das hier?
Okay, wir öffnen jetzt mal ein paar mal.
Achso, wie starte ich mehrfache Terminals?
New Window.
ok das ist jetzt hier wenn ich jetzt hier sagt
all current works was das ist eigentlich ganz cool
eigentlich ganz cool dass man das so kombination hat
wobei ich das dann bevorzugen würde wenn auch die ganzen leisten und so ausgeblendet werden
was gibt es hier noch?
do not disturb
connection, bluetooth ist auch sehr gut
soundloadstärke
ich mute mal mein Mikro
nicht, dass es damit durcheinander kommt
ok
warum wackeln die Dinger, wenn man da drüber geht?
das triggert mich
ich verstell da dran ja gar nichts
aber die wackeln trotzdem
ok
So, und hier kann man jetzt wieder sagen, nicht teilen.
Okay.
Was ist eure Lieblingsdistro?
Arch, by the way.
Beste.
Desktop Options.
Trash Folder Icon.
Mounted Drives.
So, wie kann man den Background einstellen?
Background?
Desktop?
Okay.
Background?
Bin ich jetzt zu dumm dafür?
Hier, hä?
Container-Background.
Ich bin trotzdem zu Dome 1 auszuwählen.
Wie soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Okay, Colors. Schön und gut.
Und wie stelle ich es jetzt wieder um?
Colors.
Wallpapers.
Add Image. Ja, aber das muss doch irgendwie
ein paar Default-Sachen gehen, oder?
Das Default-Image ist weg.
ok da habe ich das default image umgestellt
ich meine mir geht es irgendwo die bedienung finde ich ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig irgendwie
kann man jetzt irgendwie sagen okay ich weiß was wir machen können wir gehen jetzt einfach zu themes
Wie stelle ich denn jetzt diese Themes ein, die es am Anfang schon nochmal gab?
Okay, Leute, ich bin schon überfordert, mir das auf den Hintergrund zu ändern, Alter.
Aber dann gucken wir mal, ob wir...
Okay, Wallpaper.
Wallpaper.
hier irgendwann okay es alter karls wallpapers ach jetzt jetzt jetzt habe
ich hier wallpapers drin okay das war verbuggt verstehe
ok slideshow alle fünf minuten ändert hat das gut okay immerhin es war es war einfach
verbuggt okay so was haben wir denn sonst also die settings app haben wir uns schon
angeguckt gibt so was gibt's wobbly windows das allerwichtigste wobbly wobbly gibt es nicht
sehr gut standard anwendung was haben wir hier so dabei moment was ist der
unterschied zwischen dem hier und dem hier launcher applications
das hier ist ein bisschen ausführlicher und mit kategorien und sowas
Okay, was haben wir hier standardmäßig drauf?
Welcher Image-Viewer ist das?
Irgendein hässlicher Gnome-Image-Viewer?
Weiß man nicht.
Also, ich muss auch sagen,
irgendwie gefällt mir das mit den Fenstern und den Rahmen
und wie sich das...
Schwer zu sagen, aber...
Gefällt mir nicht so richtig
Den launcher finde ich schön der gefällt mir
Cosmic text
Hat es natürlich unbedingt einen gebraucht system
Repo man
Okay standard gnome ding
immerhin weiß etwa ans netzwerk konfiguriert okay das ist network manager
an die arzt fans wo zieht ihr eure art wiki beste aber es ist übrigens auch gar nicht so
gar nicht so so schwierig mittlerweile mit dem arzt installe arzt sind sind du kannst
aber auch einfach cash us installieren cash us ist ja ein vollwertiges arch und hat halt viele
schon vorkonfiguriert wenn wenn jetzt nicht alles vom scratch machen willst cosmic store
das ist im endeffekt in gree für abt oder so wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ein bisschen
Kategorien sind da schon dabei.
Okay, installieren wir mal
Visual Studio Code.
Ach ne, das hier ist ein FlatHub.
Das hier ist FlatHub
Übersicht.
Okay. Gibt's da auch
PW-Safe?
Tatsächlich?
Leute!
Hör mal bloß auf!
Ich will es nicht mehr sehen.
Also das ist quasi so ein Frontend.
Ist das Bazaar oder ist das was eigenes von denen?
Was ist das?
Das ist irgendwas eigenes von denen, hä?
Das ist der Cosmic Store.
gut aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut dass hier sowas dabei haben für
flat packs wo sehe ich denn jetzt ins install apps unübersichtlich jetzt jetzt
aber gut also jetzt kommen wir zum beispiel wenn das haste code code aber
flat gibt es keine eigenes das auch schon mal doof
scheint ganz gut zu laufen ja warning you are running an unofficial version of visual studio
code monka w leute gleich zerstört sich selbst
des version is running inside a container ja das wird mir schon auf den sack gehen habe ich
schon wieder keinen Bock drauf.
Wie uninstallt man
denn was?
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, kann man ausprobieren.
Uninstall, okay.
Permanent delete.
So, und wenn ich das jetzt...
VS Code gibt es ja nicht
im standardmäßigen Abtrepo,
oder?
Nee.
Ja, wie wäre denn jetzt
der beste weg zu die code of pop os zu bekommen
barthes ist es einfach
stellung von flat pack auf system ach ja geht das so flat haben
Oben links?
Ne.
Das da, oder?
Ah.
Das finde ich gut.
Dass man das machen kann.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Und jetzt?
Jetzt hat es auch ein Icon.
Und nicht gesandboxed und alles.
Oh, AI-Features.
Microsoft, geh mir nicht auf den Keks hier.
Copilot an jeder Ecke. Kekkel.
Oh nein, Sign in.
Okay.
Das ist
nicht schlecht gemacht.
Also ich sehe durchaus
das Potenzial.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde ist
Cosmic. Hier.
Pop OS Change Cursor.
How to change the cursor.
Vor 5 Jahren.
install knom tweaks warum hat er glauben ich glaube dass es das glaube ich nicht
dass wir knopft weeks installieren müssen für cosmic cosmic setting a cursor team
ist der any kraft wie zu tun ist am kosmik
moment passiert das auf x oder auf wayland kosmik ist das hier x oder wayland ich war
können wir ganz einfach ausprobieren x kill es ist ja blazing die fast rippen in rast
das finde ich aber komisch, dass es so ein großer Akt ist,
den Cursor zu ändern.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, das werden die bestimmt noch machen.
Weil ganz ehrlich, der Standard-Cursor,
der ist nun wirklich
ein bisschen hässlich.
Und auch ein dunkler Cursor,
auch wenn das Ding
einen Outline drumherum hat,
ist jetzt nicht so geil.
Da muss ich sagen, ich persönlich bin Bibata Cursor Enjoyer.
Hier, der da.
Übrigens hier, nice Feature von KDE.
Wenn ich jetzt den Cursor wackele, dann wird er größer.
Guck mal, pumpt sich auf.
Leider benutzt es keine SVGs, so wie es aussieht, weil es wird pixelig.
Pipo Fett Cursor.
So einen dicken Cursor
Brauch ich mal
Ne, also ich mag Bibata Cursor
Die finde ich einfach pock
Gerade dieses Orange
Mit dem weißen Outline ist für mich
Finde ich perfekt
Ist perfekt zu sehen auf weißen Untergründen
Oder auf hellen Untergründen
Auf dunklen Untergründen
Für mich beste Cursor Theme und beste Cursor
Es wird Unternehmens auch nie ein Standard Desktop geben.
Das sehe ich nicht.
Du brauchst Cosmic Tweaks.
Okay.
Ist das nicht irgendwo gerade Thema oder kontroverse, das SVG-Cursor umgestellt?
Okay, das ist schon kontrovers.
Okay, bei den Wayland-Leuten ist gefühlt alles kontrovers.
Ich brauch was?
Cosmic Tweaks.
Du nutzt also persönlich CacheUS als Main-Distro?
Mittlerweile ja.
früher war ich klassisch unter reinem arch by the way unterwegs mit i3 wm und
x aber mittlerweile bin ich auf cosmic nicht kosmic auf cash ios mit kde
hängen geblieben wo ich 98 99 prozent das machen kann was ich früher unter
meinem tiling window manager setup hatte plus mehr also finde ich super
tweaks
das da zwar denn das hier vorguss games
was ihr kostet cosmic desktop ok install
open
Also ich sehe da durchaus Potential in Cosmic.
Ich habe da nur eine doofe Frage jetzt noch.
Was genau ist das Alleinstellungsmerkmal von Cosmic,
dass man es neben KDE und den anderen überhaupt noch braucht?
sehe ich jetzt nämlich ehrlich gesagt den rast alter hört mir auf den rast ist jetzt
kein kein kein verkaufsargument für mich oder kein kanzler irgendwie für mich das
ist ja ist ja ganz nice das blazing lief hast du den rast
Kleine Codebase, Durchblick von Anfang an.
Sobald die alles andere eingebaut haben, was KDE und so kann, ist es auch nicht mal clean.
Color Schemes.
Ach, hier kann man auswählen.
Aber man kann hier auch keine Cursor...
Ach nee, das ist...
Shortcut.
ok ich finde gut dass die die buttons hier oben haben für schließen minimieren und so was das hat
mich bei ubuntu immer geträger dass es auf der linken seite ist mal ganz einfach abgesehen ich
brauche die buttons ähnlich weil ich das halt per short cuts macht also hier kann man so ein paar
andere sachen einstellen ja aber so wirklich so die sind sie diesen diesen dieses herausragende
Merkmal und so. Sehe ich jetzt bei
Cosmic ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also ich
ganz ehrlich, ich hätte keine Ahnung, warum ich Cosmic
jetzt verwenden sollte, anstelle von
KDE.
Gnome vs. KDE.
KDE auf jeden Fall.
Gnome mochte ich noch nie.
Das einzige,
den einzigen Flavor von Gnome,
den ich halbwegs
ertragen
konnte, waren die
Gnome 2 Zeiten.
Aber ansonsten, ne, gefällt mir nicht.
Gerade eh beste.
Also bist du mit Cache US 100%ig zufrieden oder gibt es irgendwas, was dich nicht...
Naja, wir haben ja alles noch nicht eingerichtet.
aus irgendwelchen gründen funktionieren meine devpods gerade nicht richtig hier aber weiß nicht
woran das liegt also 100 prozent ganz ehrlich 100 prozentig zufrieden bin ich nie das würde
ja heißen ich werde nie wieder was an meiner config ändern aber das ist schon ganz gut also
ich komme damit genauso gut klar wie mit meinem normalen desktop ich hier ist nichts muted ich
Ich komme damit genauso gut klar wie mit meinem alten i3, also X11 i3 Desktop.
Genau.
Wenn eine neue Kernel-Version einen Treiberfehler hat, muss man den gesamten Kernel wechseln.
Unter Windows genügt es den Fehler.
Ja, das stimmt in gewisser Weise schon.
Wobei es ja auch DKMS-Treiber gibt.
Also Treiber, die nicht direkt im Kernel sind.
und die kannst du ja auch updaten, ohne dass du ein Kernel updatest.
Aber sagen wir mal, wenn du jetzt einen Bug hast in irgendeinem Treiber,
der im Linux-Kernel drin ist und der halt erst in der nächsten Kernel-Version gefixt wird,
dann musst du es entweder selbst patchen, was ich nicht empfehlen würde,
oder du musst ihn neu kompilieren oder einen RC-Kernel oder so runterladen,
kompilieren oder, ja, also du musst halt warten, bis es dann eine neue Version gibt.
Der Vorteil ist, dass du eigentlich in der Regel einfach nur warten musst und das Problem erledigt sich von alleine.
Was ist für euch noch das nervigste an Linux?
Also, was für mich nervig an Linux ist,
ich will jetzt gar, also ich will mal so ein allgemeines Ding ansprechen,
hat jetzt nichts mit einem speziellen Desktop oder so zu tun,
oder einem fehlenden vom Standard-Desktop oder sowas.
Was mich unter Linux nervt ist,
dass ich teilweise das Gefühl habe,
die Entwicklung oder die Entwickler reiben sich gegenseitig auf.
Guckt mal, wie lang es teilweise dauert,
um popelige Sachen wie irgendwelche Tray-Icons in Wayland zu etablieren und sowas.
Oder mein Lieblingsbeispiel, was Diskussionen unter Linux angeht.
GPU beschleunigt das Abspielen von Videos im Browser.
Das geht unter Windows seit, boah, weiß ich nicht, 20 Jahren oder so.
Also GPU-Decoding.
Also, ne, Chat, für alle, denen das vielleicht noch nie aufgefallen ist, für die zeige ich das jetzt mal.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Video anmache auf YouTube hier.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt, was auch immer hier, das da an.
Beste, beste Video hier auf YouTube ansehen.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Ne, der Max ist hier auch, aber jetzt.
So, wenn ich hier ein Video starte und wir gucken jetzt mal in den Task Manager rein,
dann werdet ihr sehen, CPU-Auslastung nahezu nicht existent.
dafür jetzt dafür guckt wenn ich stoppe geht die gpu auslastung runter und ihr seht hier chrome
6% gpu decode also ich brauche so gut wie keine cpu last durch verursacht so gut wie
keine cpu last das decoden des videos macht die grafikkarte so das geht unter windows
schon ewig, schon seit 20 Jahren
oder sowas.
So.
Unter Mac geht das auch schon eine ganze
Weile, habe ich mir sagen lassen. Ich habe ja selbst kein Mac.
Unter Linux geht das
erst seit
3, 4
Jahren, also out of the box
ganz gut. Da war eine
riesen Diskussion am Start.
Woran liegt es? Liegt es
am Browserhersteller? Liegt es an
X11, liegt's an Wayland,
liegt's an Mesa, liegt's am Kern,
liegt's am Grafikkartentreiber, liegt's an den
Grafikkartenhersteller, liegt's an der
ach, was weiß ich
und da haben die da rumgemacht
und hin und her
und alle, die das wollten, mussten
ewig warten oder sinnlos rumpatchen,
sinnlose Browser-Addons installieren
und selbst heute
funktionieren nicht mal
alle Videos, alle Videoformate,
die die Grafikkarte eigentlich
kann, out of the box unter Linux.
in jedem Browser. Also das sind so Dinge,
die brauchen teilweise ewig
und sehr diskutieren, die Sachen.
Auf der einen Seite
ist das ein Vorteil,
aber ist in vielen Fällen auch ein Nachteil,
wie das
so läuft.
Also manchmal denkt man sich, Alter,
kann doch nicht sein.
Guckt euch Wayland an.
Wayland
ist ja gestartet als
wir machen jetzt
quasi, wir nehmen uns alles, was
was man braucht von X
und machen das nur in gut. Und den Rest lassen wir
weg. So ist Wayland gestartet.
Und Wayland ist ja alt.
Wayland ist von, weiß ich nicht, 2005
oder so, wo das gestartet wurde.
Das ist auch schon 20 Jahre alt.
Hier, 2008.
Wayland ist auch schon an die 20 Jahre halt.
Und so richtig benutzbar
ist Wayland erst die letzten 2-3 Jahre
geworden. Und es gibt immer noch
ein paar dinger wo es probleme gibt ja so automatisierung im desktop bereich so
hier klickt dahin klickt dahin drückt diese taste drückt diese taste so was
dass das hat das ist jetzt benutzbar ja aber es fehlen immer noch dinger
oder denkt mich an warum dauert das alles so extrem lang gut wenn du wegen
jedem icon hier teilweise 33 tage das zeit diskutiert dann wundert mich das
nicht
ja also dieses ewig lange rum diskutiere und sich gegenseitig die zu die schuld
zugeschrieben geht mir unter linux auf den sack
so das war es das was für mich das nervigste unter den oxen ist etwas aber
auch noch ein schönes Beispiel,
ähm,
wobei das jetzt eher so ein
Allow me to interject for a moment
Meme, Insert,
ist,
Emacs.
Emacs
konnte
mit einem Merch-Request auf einmal,
oder mit einem Patch,
konnte das auf einmal
Emoji-Text
unter macOS.
So.
und das war eigentlich ganz gut und die Mac-Entwickler, die iMacs verwenden, haben sich auch gefreut.
So, es wurde dann auch schon überlegt, wollen wir nicht ein Windows-Patch einbauen und sonst was
und dann wurde der Patch aus iMacs wieder rausgeschmissen oder nicht gemerged, irgendwas, gab es auch wieder Diskussionen drunter
Und der Grund war, man möchte kein Mac OS Only Feature merchen, solange es nicht eine freie Open Source Alternative zu der Mac Emoji Implementierung gibt, die potenziell auf allen Betriebssystemen läuft.
Ja, das ist bei Emacs und die sind da besonders hardcore drauf, aber das sind so Dinger, das versteht doch kein User.
Kein User versteht es, dass eine sinnvolle Funktion aus dem Produkt, was er verwendet und was bei ihm unter macOS gut funktioniert,
wieder rausgepatcht wird wegen Problemen unter Linux oder Windows.
Oder es gibt ja nicht mal Probleme, vorhandene Implementierung unter Linux und Windows.
das versteht doch keiner und aber das ist das ist im ex und da sind die besonders hardcore leute am
start da wundert mich nicht aber so dinge kommen halt vor und das ist halt schon vielfach
unverständlich ja ich bin übrigens gar nicht sicher ob die max mittlerweile im support hat
und wir sind uns einig im ort support ist sehr wichtig guck hier auch im ort support
und und auch ein sehr ein ganz tolles feature was ich letztens festgestellt habe was jeder
streamer braucht ein afg klo alias und am besten dann noch dann am besten afg klo
und oben ascii aquarium um dass der chat in der zeit auch noch was sieht
der beste anzeige für ich muss mal aufs klo unten flackert afg klo und oben läuft
AskIquarium.
Da kann dann der Chat,
der immer
um
Aufmerksamkeit ringt,
wenn mal zwei Minuten nichts los ist,
dann geht das
besser.
Wetter fehlt noch.
Ja, das Problem ist,
was juckt euch? Das Wetter bei mir.
TikTok.
Ja, TikTok ist auch so ein Ding, ne?
Ich hab's euch ja schon mal gesagt.
Ich war vor nicht allzu langer Zeit beim Friseur.
Und der Friseur musste dann mal ans Telefon, weil irgendjemand angerufen hat in der Zeit, wo er gerade am Schneiden war.
Also ich hab da auf der Bank gesessen und gewartet, bis ich dran gekommen bin.
und dann ist der friseur da war keine ahnung eine minute vielleicht am am telefon und da hat der typ
wo der friseur halt vorher frisiert hat hat unter unter diesem tuch was man so über sich hat beim
friseur hat das ein handy rausgeholt sich drei tik tok shorts angeguckt bis der friseur fertig
telefonieren waren und wir auf der die fertig telefonieren war wieder weggesteckt er hat es
einfach nicht ertragen eine minute kein input zu haben das ging nicht erst erst mal tik tok
Shorts starten.
Okay, so.
Cosmic haben wir uns angeguckt.
Popo S haben wir uns angeguckt.
Okay, zu Popo S sage ich mal nichts.
Da haben wir uns heute nicht wirklich viel angeguckt.
Cosmic, ehrlich gesagt, ja,
ist benutzbar, ist ganz okay.
Aber ich sehe überhaupt nicht
den Grund, warum ich das versus KDE
benutzen sollte.
Soviel zum Thema Popo S.
beziehungsweise eher kosmik stellt noch irgendwas was ich mir angucken soll
bevor ich ausmachen das nächste installiert
jetzt klar und genau umhören auf ok chat wir machen es gleich ich installiere
jetzt ich installiere als cash ios und wenn dann die auswahl kommt welches
welchen desktop installieren wollen dann frage ich euch noch mal
sachen silva dankeschön für den sub exzellenz der subscription
rock dazu kann ich nur sagen
der teiling window manager probiere ich nicht mehr aus ich habe früher einen
teiling window manager benutzt kann ich dir kann ich dir zeigen weil mein power
auf kann ich dir zeigen wenn man die mein altes streaming linux anmachen das
war...
Achso, in Cosmic. Okay, jetzt ist...
Dann hab ich's nicht gecheckt. Zu spät.
Wir haben's nur kurz ausprobiert.
Fand's auch ganz, ganz gut.
Das ist tatsächlich... Okay, das lass ich mir gefallen.
Das wäre tatsächlich
so ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal oder so ein Merkmal, wo ich sagen würde,
ja, dafür wäre Cosmic sinnvoll.
Wenn man gerne zwischen Floating
und Tiling umschaltet
und auf einem Desktop Tiling hat,
auf einem Floating und so, dann ist vielleicht das ganz cool
mit Cosmic. Aber das kann man mit KDE
auch machen also mit kde kannst du auch tiling sachen ein ein und umschalten
so das ist mein alter desktop hier
ja das war die 3 wm auf x11 basis mit profi als launcher firefox als browser western als terminal
ja und da haben wir jahrelang haben wir hier so drauf geschrieben und das funktioniert ja auch
immer noch top kann man nicht sagen funktioniert auch schnell ohne irgendwelches gelerke oder sonst
was mich nicht manch aro nee das ist arch by the way arch linux x86 also ganz ganz vor einigen
jahren hatte ich man ja by the way wenn ich das jetzt abdecken würde update das überhaupt noch
Ich update es nicht
Ich brauch die Kiste eh nicht mehr
So, so sah das aus
Versuch mal Niri
das ist kronen habe ich ja schon mal ein video zu angeguckt vom ansatz her interessant aber
ich habe halt überhaupt keine anwendungszweck was das kdm dafür also ich will auch keine
teile nur manager ausprobieren sodann in salin wirklich mal so komplette desktop environments
dann gehen wir mal hier hin cash us zack ok muss man ganz schnell
reinklicken wir wollen starten von cd cd rom drive
Jetzt backt das wieder.
Das ist so cringe, Alter.
Das ist aber ein Vmware-Bug.
Kanisterkoppel,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription hier.
und um nichts zu sagen.
So, erinnert mich dran gleich,
ich muss einen Snapshot machen,
wenn ich im Installer
bei der Auswahl bin
für
mag das nicht vielleicht jetzt den Desktop
starten irgendwie?
wenn ich im installer bei der auswahl bin für desktop environments so launch
installer
warum installiert du nicht auf deiner hardware ich will dass du hast recht ich
habe snapshots aber ich will es trotzdem nicht versauen
außerdem bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ob man das nach ob es dieses menü
nachträglich noch gibt okay wir wollen nicht deutsch wir wollen wie war das im
American English muss man jetzt machen.
Bin ich jetzt zu dumm?
Hallo?
BTF?
American English.
Next.
Berlin.
Keyboard.
Germany.
No dead keys.
Was?
Gibt's das nicht?
Okay, dann einfach Default.
Ja, das ist okay.
Komm, wir gehen auch nochmal sicher, dann funktioniert es auch auf jeden Fall.
Crap.
Erase Disk.
Encrypt sparen wir uns jetzt mal.
Gibt es inzwischen eine vernünftige Alternative für VMware?
Es gibt nur eine Alternative zu VMware.
Also unter Windows und unter Linux hast du noch Virtual Manager mit KVM.
Aber es gibt eigentlich nur VirtualBox als Alternative.
sonst so richtig auf desktop virtualisierung spezialisiertes cross
plattform gibt es vor allem bei workstation virtual box soll es geht
überall unter merck hast noch parallel unter linux hast du dann auch wird
manager mit kvm aber so richtig alternative gibt es eigentlich nur
virtual box und der vergangenheit habe ich immer gesagt vor allem bei
workstation viel viel besser als virtual box seit der 25er version backt das
teilweise so heftig rum,
dass ich da gar nicht unbedingt mitgehen würde.
Okay, jetzt
muss ich, Leute, jetzt muss ich
snapshotten. Snapshot,
take Snapshot.
Snapshot
getaked. Also,
Plasma müssen wir nicht ausprobieren. Plasma
habe ich hier auf meiner,
Plasma habe ich hier. Das müssen wir dann ausprobieren.
So, was haben wir denn? Gnome?
Cosmic?
Cinnamon, Budgie,
Mate, XFCE,
LXQT, LXDE.
Was ist UKUI?
Was es nicht alles gibt, Alter.
Okay, Openbox sparen wir uns heute auch.
Auch wenn es für die
Weeps unter uns anscheinend ganz toll vorkonfiguriert ist.
Ich kann nicht alles installieren.
Ich kann immer nur eins auswählen.
Im nächsten Schritt kann ich glaube ich alles installieren, oder?
Openbox ist auch nice.
Openbox ist halt super minimalistisch.
Ich habe also ganz, ganz früher
habe ich auch hauptsächlich Openbox verwendet.
Okay, komm.
NixOS.
Den Nix Package Manager benutze ich.
Aber NixOS nicht.
Okay, also.
Also, in der VM muss ich Sway, Hyperland
und sowas gar nicht ausprobieren.
Das läuft in der VM nicht, wegen Grafikproblem.
Okay, Gnome, next.
Also, hier, komm. Gnome,
Cosmic haben wir schon. Cinnamon,
Bucci, Mate,
XFCE, LXQT,
Moment, äh, LXQT
ist das neue LXDE, gell? War das nicht so?
UKUI?
Komm, wir installieren einfach alles, bam.
Open Box
Next
Axt
Omega
Eccle
Okay, next
Okay
Insta.
Bam.
Gib ihm Cash.us.
Auf.
Ich hoffe,
die aktuelle Installer-ISO ist nicht wieder kaputt,
wie die vom letzten Dezember.
Und es funktioniert.
Prage.
Chat, mit was wollen wir anfangen?
Gnome, oder?
Da kann ich flamen. Ich mag Gnome überhaupt gar nicht.
Gnome Desktop ist halt gut für Leute, die es exakt auf diese eine Art und Weise haben wollen, wie die Gnome Entwickler es auch haben wollen.
Ansonsten wirst du mit Gnome nicht glücklich.
Bei der Installation...
Äh...
Okay.
No.
Äh, gut.
Snapshot.
Revert.
Yes.
Hast du einen Zweck?
Ne, hab ich nicht. Einfach mal wieder angucken.
Ich mein, ich hab ja zum größten Teil den ganzen
Campbell mir schon mal alles angeguckt, über die
Jahre, ja. Aber, da sind
halt manchmal auch ziemlich outdated Infos
dabei, was ich so im Kopf hab.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich früher auch
auf, äh, ups,
jetzt spinnt hier wieder vor allem herum,
was ich früher auch manchmal verwendet hab,
ähm, unter Linux,
für ganz alte Kisten,
die aber einen GUI gebraucht haben.
Da habe ich hier
Ice WM 95 oder so hieß das, glaube ich.
Ice WM?
Das ist so ziemlich der hässlichste
Window Desktop Manager Kram,
den ihr euch vorstellen könnt.
Hier, da.
Ja, so sah das damals aus.
Ist das nicht hübsch?
Man könnte sagen, es ist zweckmäßig, oder?
Das war noch deutlich leichtgewichtiger als XFCE.
Mittlerweile ist es Vintage, ja hast du recht.
So, okay, dann sagen wir jetzt Gnome.
next ok next hoffen wir mal dass es jetzt geht 0w next install chat was
machen wir wenn es nicht geht
dann nehmen wir chat ich habe doch letztens im cash ios runtergeladen was auf jeden fall
funktioniert hat was habe ich denn hier cash ios linux achtet nie das ist das gleiche was ich
das letzte mal auch habe als gleiche war ich letzte mal runtergeladen habe und installiert
habe das müsste eigentlich funktionieren vielleicht haben wir es auch nur kaputt
gemacht das kann sein dass wir es kaputt gemacht haben weil wir da so viele desktop umgebung
ausgewählt haben genau das auf die kvm hochgeladen
ja das kann durchaus sein dass das kaputt gemacht haben
Ja, CacheOS?
Oh ne.
Der kackt bestimmt wieder ab
Hör bei Retrieving Packages
Oh ne, ho, ho, er macht was
Okay, er ist auch glaube ich
Jetzt schon weiter als das letzte Mal, ne
Moment, hab ich da gerade gesehen, dass der
Fortran installiert?
Hab ich das richtig gesehen?
Stand da gerade Fortran?
Warum zum Teufel
Lip G Fortran.
Was kommt als nächstes? Kobol?
Eins kann man ja sagen, die Cache-OS-Installation dürfte durchaus ein bisschen schneller gehen.
Ach ja, und das fand ich übrigens bei Pop!OS auch ganz gut.
Der Installer, der war ziemlich straightforward und problemlos und schnell.
Was Lisp hat er auch installiert.
Oh, ich weiß nicht, was er da alles für Dependencies hat, Mensch.
Lisp. Fortran und Lisp, Alter.
Die ganzen
Emacs-Enjoyer, die stehen auf Lisp.
Weil die Emacs-Plugins in Lisp,
in diesem Emacs-Lisp-Dialekt
progerst.
Gibt es irgendwelche Desktops, die besonders hervorzuheben sind unter CacheOS?
Also ich weiß, offiziell sagen sie immer, man soll halt KDE benutzen.
Also das sagen sie nicht.
Die sagen, KDE ist quasi das Aushängeschild.
Gibt es noch irgendwas anderes?
Was besonders gut ist?
All done.
Restart.
Gnome, na da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das besonders gut ist.
Wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer Gnome-Fan.
Kogas?
Okay, Max
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Wär dir eh nicht drauf gekommen
Äh
Chat, warum sieht die Schrift so kacke aus?
Die Schrift sieht richtig
Äh
Ah
Der hat rausgesoomt
E17 oder wie das hieß, das ist auch so ein ganz spezieller Fall von Desktop-Umgebung, ja.
Welches Dateisystem benutzt du? Standardmäßig BTFS, ist zumindest standardmäßig ausgewählt, aber du kannst sogar ZFS benutzen.
Also du kannst im Dropdown, ich glaube standardmäßig BTFS selected.
So, welcome to CacheOS. Ja gut, mehr brauchen wir eigentlich hier nicht, nur das juckt da nicht.
Zack.
So.
Ich krieg schon Anfälle.
Ich krieg schon Anfälle bei diesem Startmenü hier, ey.
Da krieg ich echt...
Da dreh ich schon durch, wenn ich das sehe.
Man drückt die Windows-Taste, es zoomt so hässlich raus.
Ist das für Mobile?
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Das ist nicht für Mobile.
Sieht so aus, ja.
Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was mit den Gnome-Leuten los ist.
Wie startet man überhaupt das Startmenü hier?
Und vor allem, was soll denn dieses komische Icon hier oben überhaupt bedeuten?
Na gut, okay.
Also, jetzt starten wir den Application Launcher.
Keyboard.
Okay, kann man Shortcuts wenigstens in Gnome machen?
Keyboard, Shortcuts
Seht ihr irgendwas Shortcuts?
Wie kannst du mir Shortcuts?
Okay, ich will Launcher
Launcher
Launch, Search
Äh
Wie heißt das hier?
Apps
Super A
Ah, Super A muss man drücken
Ja, ich will ja auch
dieses Sucheding starten.
Aber du musst ja erst hier irgendwie...
Windows-Taste
und A. Dann kommt
dieser Launcher.
Da sind tausend
Sachen drin. Ungruppiert.
Man weiß nicht, was was ist.
CacheUS Package Installer.
Cache Update.
Das ist glaube ich der...
Das ist im Prinzip einfach nur was,
was in den Pac-Man-Update aufruft.
So, also.
Es ist sehr minimalistisch.
Ein Firefox am Start.
Und ansonsten...
Shelly.
Was ist das?
Äh
Noch mal einen Package Manager
Gab's hier nicht
Cache Package Installer
Boah die Schrift
WTF
Das ist ja komplett broken
Okay das sieht alles ein bisschen
Mittelalter mäßig aus
stelle maschert ein wenn du direkt haben willst ja das mache ich mal warte mal dort katz search
das war jetzt auf windows taste d ja das schon besser und hier wieder aus taste die eckel
Package.
Ja, das ist schon deutlich angenehm.
Aber ich krieg Anfälle bei diesem Rauszoomen
und so. Boah.
Ich mag halt einfach kein Gnome.
So, das ist so ziemlich der
minimalistischste Package-Manager, den ich mir
vorstellen kann. Der... Moment.
Den kann ich...
Was ist das?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ich kann den nicht kleiner machen.
Das heißt, für alles unter 1080p
ungeeignet.
Das sieht doch noch kacke aus.
Search Package
via Code.
Okay, immerhin ist es schnell.
Das muss man ja immer lassen.
Okay, wie installiere ich das jetzt?
Install Selected. Yes.
Okay, das ist sehr zweckmäßig,
aber es funktioniert.
Funktion.
Meinetwegen.
Ich meine, realistisch betrachtet,
ich würde es immer über die serie installieren also realistisch betrachtet konsole war terminal
aber überhaupt ein terminal nach aller kritik also normalerweise immer sagen hier packen wir
installieren jetzt erstmal normalerweise würde ich würde ich immer sagen hier ich will wie es
code installed was hat er hier verschmerzen übrigens zsh bestes das
standardmäßig standardmäßig hat cashew es fisch das irritiert mich immer so
dann gucken wir mal ach so
Man kann direkt
Search hier machen.
Windows-Taste ist das gleiche, wie ich hier
hingelegt habe.
Windows-Taste macht das standardmäßig schon.
Dass man dann, wenn man tippt in den
Search-Dings. Okay, dann ist es
gar nicht so schlecht, wie ich gesagt habe.
P-Ticks.
Was für ein Ding?
Was?
Wie?
x
pt pt pt
Ja okay dass das sieht tatsächlich aus wie in den knoven default ja
Christian herrgert hat das geproggert
das ist die fall warum ist eigentlich dass die volk normal nicht mehr klar
so genau terminal klingt doch nach dem default terminal
So Müll ist es gar nicht.
Aber wir können trotzdem flamen.
Ne, Konsole ist das KDE-Standard.
Früher gab es Gnome Terminal.
So.
Ähm.
Vias Code.
Warum nimmt
VSCode nicht das
Standard OS Theme
Normalerweise macht es das
Also wenn ich
Wenn ich
Wenn ich jetzt hier mal rüber gehe
In mein Linux
In mein KDE
Achso, da soll ich vielleicht VSCode mal installieren
Wir installieren das Original
Official Binary Version
Visual Studio Code Bin
Okay, wir vergleichen das mal
Ist das hier auch so?
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass das standardmäßig
Aber schauen wir mal
Code
Ne
Da ist Dark Theme, so wie es sich gehört
Und noch viel wichtiger
Wobbly Windows
Haben wir hier
Effects, gibt es sowas
Wobbly Windows
Ne, Settings
Die müssen wir uns mal ansehen, Tweaks, aha
Standardmäßig
Extensions has moved
Na dann
Aber hier ist anscheinend standardmäßig
Checkt es
Nicht, wenn das unter Gnome im Dark Theme ist
Ja, das ist ja auch so ein Ding
Ändere mal ein Theme unter Gnome
Das geht halt auch wieder nicht.
Appearance.
Was? Settings is ready?
Achso.
Moment. Default ist was?
Ach, das war im Light Mode.
Deswegen. Ich dachte, weil das so dunkel ist,
das ist Dark Mode.
Okay, dann stellen wir Gnome in Dark Mode.
Das ist auch okay.
Aha.
So, dann können wir jetzt nämlich nochmal
Wischel Studio Code starten
und jetzt ist es bestimmt auch dark. Jawoll.
Eins muss man ja sagen,
schnell starten tut das Kram ja hier.
Bam.
Ja, ein bisschen Motion
sickness kann man ja schon kriegen.
Ein bisschen kann man schon kriegen.
Gnome hat die schrecklichsten
Wallpapers.
Da hast du schon irgendwo recht, ja.
Also dieses
Rauszoomen für das Menü, damit werde ich nie
warm werden.
Animations.
Äh.
Äh. Wie jetzt?
Wo ist es denn?
Ach da.
magnify the desktop, excellent
animationen, weiss nicht ob man die ausschalten kann, suchen wir mal
Animations.
Hm.
Seeing?
Der readet gar nichts
gerade bei mir.
Animation-Effekts. Hier.
Boah, aber ohne Mist.
Da werde ich ja
noch mehr motion sick.
Ohne Motion. Wenn das so hin und her springt.
Das ist noch schlimmer, ne?
Bist du auf Gnome 50?
Äh
Sehe ich das hier irgendwo?
About
Gnome Version
Äh, wie?
Warum steht hier nicht die Version?
steht da steht 49 ja wo denn ich sehe es nicht wo ist es denn statt es hier
klover 49 ok ok gibt noch kein 50 hier die fault apps kalender text editor am
beste Text-Tutorial ist immer die beste Anzeige für
einen Kalender.
Und letztendlich, das ist halt auch das
eines der Sachen, was mir an Gnome
halt gar nicht gefällt. Wenn euch das
so wie es jetzt ist, nicht gefällt,
ihr habt es ja gesehen, ihr könnt daran nichts ändern.
Entweder so
Gnome benutzen und gut finden, wie das die
Gnome-Entwickler sich standardmäßig gedacht haben
oder Pech gehabt.
Was ich vielleicht noch ganz interessant finde,
können wir hier rüberschieben.
Unterschiedliche Desktops und so.
Ansonsten ist es schon
benutzbar. So ist es nicht.
Aber mein Fall ist es
beim besten Willen nicht.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal
hier, wie einfach es ist, den Mauszeiger zu
ändern.
Ich kann euch jetzt schon
sagen,
Cursor.
Point and clicking.
Äh, what?
Das geht nur über Tweaks, oder?
Extensions.
No installed extensions.
Und wie installe ich jetzt Extensions?
Hier drüber?
Maus.
To find an edX.
Moment, ich muss da hingehen im Browser
und das runterladen?
Wirklich, ernsthaft?
Was ist das?
The fuck?
Das ist ja grausam.
By Popularity.
Okay.
Cursor.
Oder was soll ich denn da suchen jetzt?
Ion Cursor.
Cursor Size.
Light Dark Cursor Theme.
Was sind das für Tweaks?
VPN.
So.
Wie minimiere ich hier überhaupt was?
War das nicht so, dass Gnome kein Minimieren-Button hat?
Ich bilde mir doch ein, das war doch so, oder?
Die haben doch den Minimieren-Button wegrationalisiert irgendwie.
Minimieren gibt's nicht.
Also Chat, wer sein Fenster minimieren will, der hat Pech.
So, Tweaks.
Tweaks.
um
minima es geht das vielleicht aber nicht viel
Titel bei Exes Doppelklick Maxima es will klicken an
Titel bei Bartens Maxima es minima es
da muss man kaum neu starten danach oder
mehr ich krieg auch bei Knochen waren an immer immer immer Anfälle
an die hier kommt man jetzt haben was
es gibt buttons
Minimieren Maximum Schließen Buttons.
Das geht aber offiziell nicht.
Das geht nur über Gnome Tweaks.
So, und jetzt Cursor.
Appearance. Cursor.
Äh.
Wenn es da nichts zur Auswahl gibt,
kann es sein, dass ich noch keine zusätzlichen Cursor installiert habe?
Genau.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt erstmal was installieren.
Okay, da muss ich mal kurz checken.
Chat, da muss ich mal kurz checken,
ähm,
welchen Cursor ich hier installiert habe.
Bibata Cursor Theme.
Okay.
Dann installieren wir das mal.
ist der cursor der default cursor ist gar nichts das ist ein dunkler maus
kurs einem dark theme gefällt mir nicht wie bartha cursor team gibt es das
vielleicht auch direkt die bartha cursor theme yes yes
Jetzt muss ich erstmal 3 Stunden kompilieren oder so, nur für den Mauscursor.
Seht mal Leute, es ist nicht so einfach hier einfach einen Mauscursor nachzuinstallieren.
Ich finde es auch blöd, dass
CacheUS Bibata noch nicht mit
aufgenommen hat, weil, ganz ehrlich,
für mich ist das beste Cursor-Theme, was es gibt.
Und sonst, die haben ja total viel da mittlerweile mit aufgenommen.
Übrigens, der Input laggt manchmal ein bisschen.
Das finde ich auch sehr fragwürdig.
Da weiß ich jetzt aber nicht, ob es an Gnome liegt
oder hier an Virtualisierung. Wahrscheinlich eher an Virtualisierung.
Ach ja.
Okay. Chat.
Wenn man Fenster minimiert, ne?
Ach, dann kann man die so...
Über Tab kann man die dann nicht mehr aufmachen, oder?
Doch.
Okay, dann probieren wir das jetzt mal aus.
Hier, Bibata.
Moment, wir müssen zu Tweaks.
Erstmal Tweaks wieder zumachen wahrscheinlich.
Tweaks.
Äh, Maus.
Ne.
Appearance.
Cursor.
Aha.
Bibata Original Amber.
Bibata.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ich will Modern Amber.
Excellent.
Beste Cursor.
Kann man jetzt vielleicht die Maus-Cursor-Größe noch anpassen?
Das geht hier auch nicht über Tweaks, oder?
Maus Cursor Größe anpassen.
Hier kann man nur den Cursor ändern.
Die Größe kann man hier nicht drüber ändern.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Guck mal.
Gnome change Cursor Size.
Easily change Cursor Size in Gnome.
Was?
Man braucht eine Extension dafür.
You can go to seeing.
Was?
Accessibility.
Das finde ich übrigens auch nervig, dass das nicht in Vordergrund gleich gepackt wird.
Seeing.
Cursor size.
Okay.
Da muss ich dran gewöhnen, wo die Dinger sind.
Das geht ja klar.
Ein bisschen doof, dass man
über Tweaks machen muss und so.
Aber jetzt haben wir es zu einem halbwegs funktionierenden Desktop
customised.
Aber nicht, dass du trotz...
Mir gefällt es einfach nicht.
Ein Magnifier? Wollen wir mal gucken, ob wir eine Extension mit einem Magnifier finden?
Magni... was?
Custom Magnifier.
Was ist das?
Magnifier.
settings
wahrscheinlich
ja gut man kann summen das hatten wir ja vorhin schon gefunden aber nee so was was nur hier so am
cursor dass das macht das wäre schon cool makes a number of improvements in the magnifier mode
The pointer moves smoothly, corrects the print...
Äh.
Und was genau macht es jetzt?
Ich mach jetzt einfach mal install, bam.
Ich will irgendwelche random Sachen installieren.
Ach so.
Click here to install browser extension.
Okay.
Install.
Ich muss bestimmt nochmal Loy laden, hä?
What?
No such native application
Okay
Anscheinend
Wollen wir nochmal zu?
Also irgendwie, ich werd einfach kein Fan von Gnome
Es ist nicht kompatibel mit meiner Version
Ja, geil
Was passiert hier? Wir flamen Gnome
Der scheiß Gnome
Das fandst du nicht.
Remove extension.
Bam.
Und jetzt muss ich es downloaden.
Ach, fuck.
Nee, Leute.
Das will ich nicht.
Geh mal fort.
Nee, geh mal fort, Alter.
Kein Bock auf Gnome.
Da, geh mal weg, Alter.
Nee.
Also, ich war kein Fan von Gnome und wer zwei...
Und wird es wohl auch nie mehr werden.
Okay, ein bisschen teilen kann man halbwegs, aber nach unten teilen kann man nicht.
Kann ich denn jetzt, wenn ich sagen wir mal hier...
Oh, dieses rausgesumme, das macht...
Da wird es mir wirklich fast verschlechtert bei.
Äh, was?
Ich habe ein Screenshot gemacht, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das gemacht habe gerade.
Ich will noch ein weiteres Terminal starten.
Ach, da muss ich jetzt rechtsklicken und sagen New Window.
Boah, ey, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
So, und das kann ich jetzt aber wenigstens so anordnen, ne?
Das ist dann halbwegs gescheit.
Naja.
Kann ich jetzt hier?
Okay, das checkt er wenigstens.
Was wir hatten bisher, wir hatten Pop!OS mit Cosmic und jetzt Gnome.
Also ich bin kein Gnome-Fan, ich werde auch kein Gnome-Fan mehr werden, Leute.
Da gibt es nichts zu machen
Soll ich irgendwas ausprobieren?
Ansonsten gehen wir jetzt zum nächsten Desktop über
Wie war Cosmic?
Besser als Gnome
Was ich bei Cosmic nicht verstanden habe ist
Was jetzt der große Seller sein soll
Versus zum Beispiel sowas wie KDE
Also sprich, warum sollte ich Cosmic verwenden
versus zum Beispiel KDE. Das habe ich nicht kapiert.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
benutzbar
und es ist besser als Gnome.
So.
Snapshots.
Revert.
Bam.
Die Frage, ob Cosmic oder Gnome
Dann würde ich Cosmic bevorzugen
Ja, aber ist das wirklich ein Seller für mich?
Was juckt mich, ob das Native Wayland ist
Oder gar kein X mehr kann
Ich meine, ich kann KDE auch unter Wayland benutzen
Und
Also ist mir doch als User wurscht, so
Ob die mal unter X gelaufen sind
Oder nicht
ok so als in die sinne man ist hier man haben wir schon öfters ausprobiert unter
und damit das müssen das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich budget es ist extrem modular jede
komponente ist ein wayland klein jede komponente ist auch ein eigener prozess und was habe ich
davon?
Neri kann ich nicht ausprobieren hier.
Das läuft nicht in der VM gescheit.
Das müsste ich auf dem Mini-PC höchstens mal
installieren.
Ist das eigentlich unter
Wayland immer noch so,
dass
man nichts
bestimmen kann, so ohne
weiteres, wo eine Anwendung gestartet
wird? Also zum Beispiel,
ich habe jetzt eine anwendung die will ich immer hier in diesem an dieser stelle gestartet haben
oder musen das funktioniert nicht mehr das funktioniert das funktioniert nur wenn es
die wenn es die desktops unterstützen also ich glaube mit kde und irgendwelchen fenster rules
und so kann man es wahrscheinlich jetzt schon machen ich fände das super ich finde das super
wenn es eine gute alternative noch zu kde und glauben gibt wenn die architektur gut ist und
es den hilft quasi bessere oder schneller zu entwickeln bessere features einzubauen und
das stabil zu halten super so war ich wie gesagt ich habe jetzt jetzt schon jetzt schon muss man
ja auch muss man vielleicht ein bisschen positiver sagen ich habe nichts gefunden
bei cosmic was mich jetzt so abgeschreckt hätte dass ich nicht damit arbeiten könnte
so jetzt ist der lehrer banshee wieder mal die gleiche geschichte heckl blub
heilig secure passwort wieder die race install zack und switch ich mal wie das immer rum packt
wenn man das hier dann zwischen wir mal hier auf die auf die echte native linux
kiste guck mal ein bisschen im chat bis cash us installiert also das ist
tatsächlich okay du hast eine sache die ich jetzt sehe du hast da ein bisschen
größere firma dahinter das finde ich natürlich schon mal nicht schlecht da
ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen zug in der entwicklung dahinter und es wird
nicht drei jahre darüber diskutiert ob das icon jetzt ein pixel weiter links oder rechts sein
soll oder ob dieses icon okay ist oder ob das vielleicht besser ein svg sein sollte oder also
damit er wird weniger verdiskutiert könnte ich mir vorstellen was ja sich für einen neuen desktop
durchaus als vorteil erweisen könnte einfach weil er deutlich schneller aufholt das ist tatsächlich
ein vorteil ja dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich so in drei vier jahren noch mal gucken wie sich
cosmic dann entwickelt hat vielleicht sind wir dann so weit und sagen cosmic beste und
ich verwende dann hauptsächlich cosmic glaube ich zwar noch nicht jetzt aber man weiß ja nie
kommen wir mal roadmap gucken cosmic desktop
Aber dass er noch richtig schreibt.
Cosmic Epoch.
Epoch.
2 and 3.
Roadmap.
Aha.
Das Ort ist kalt.
Monka W.
Das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch.
Ey, das ist das erste Mal
Dass ich so ein Kanban-Board
Auf GitHub gesehen hab
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, dass sie das können
Wo, kann, wusstet ihr das?
Wusstet ihr, dass GitHub sowas hat?
Ja, ich nicht
Hab ich noch nie gesehen
Ja, GitLab hat sowas.
Jira hat auch sowas.
Wie die coolen Leute es aussprechen.
Lip Cosmic.
Eigentlich ist es irgendwie doch eine coole Sache.
Müssen wir mal in drei, vier Jahren gucken,
wie es dann ausschaut.
Jaira, genau.
Experimental Zones Protocol Merge to Wayland After...
Ja, da haben sie wahrscheinlich 5 Jahre...
Das ist halt so diese typische Entwicklung.
Das geht so langsam, Alter.
Das geht so langsam.
Weil die zerdiskutieren das immer 50 Jahre lang.
Multi-Window-Application.
Gibt es ja glücklicherweise kaum noch.
Ganz ehrlich, die einzige Multi-Window-Application ist GIMP, die mir so einfällt.
Fällt noch irgendjemand eine Multi-Window-Application ein?
Altium.
Was ist denn das?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Altium-Designer.
Ach, das ist für PCBs oder irgendwie sowas, oder?
Ah.
Okay, das ist...
Aber es ist ja schon mal sehr nice, dass es überhaupt unter Linux funktioniert.
Pock.
Jetbrains Sachen? Nö, die sind nicht Multi-Window.
Was ist da dran Multi-Window?
Guck.
Ach, macht es nicht, okay.
Okay, Jetbrain Sachen ist nix Multi-Window.
Die haben ein Terminal und sowas, aber das ist ja alles im gleichen Fenster.
CPU-Auslastung geht hier steil.
Du kannst doch einen Tab in einem extra Window anzeigen.
Ja gut, das ist richtig.
ich kann auch hier einfach sagen new window ja ein neues projekt auch mit new window das geht
auch aber ich glaube dass es damit nicht gemeint weil dann hast du ja einfach die das kommt die
komplette idee zweimal mein zugeben multi window ja ach das ist nicht mehr multi window das aktuelle
GIMP. Da siehst du mal, wie lange ich das schon nicht
mehr verwendet habe.
Ja. GIMP Multi
Window.
So sah das mal aus.
Guck. Das waren alles einzelne
Fenster, die du gebraucht hast, um
für eine Anwendung.
Und jetzt geht das anscheinend besser unter
Wayland. Exzellent.
So, gucken wir mal.
CacheOS installiert.
Restart.
Das kommt bestimmt noch aus
GTK 2 Tagen,
wo man gedacht hat, man muss das so machen.
GTK ist ja eigentlich das GIMP Toolkit.
Benutzt Gimp eigentlich überhaupt noch die aktuellsten GTK-Versionen?
Warum ist es komplett schwarz?
Okay, ist es nicht.
Ich sehe keine Maus.
Chat.
Baji hat keine Maus bei mir.
Moment.
Es hat keine Maus?
Was ist das?
The fuck?
Ja, es hat ja offiziell eine Maus.
Ihr seht ja, dass ich die Maus bewege, aber ich sehe die Maus nicht.
Und starten kann ich auch nichts.
Ey, das kannst du ja...
Das kannst du ja einmal komplett klicken.
Okay.
Ich probiere mal was.
alles manchmal backt wir machen mal die excel excel rät für die graphics aus
Maus war nicht im Budget, ja.
Äh.
Ah, Chat, ich hab ne Maus.
Vielleicht hätte ich so einfach mal rebooten müssen.
Äh.
Chat, ich kann mich nicht mal anmelden.
Ne, jetzt ist Caps Lock an.
Äh.
Was ist LabWCR?
Ich meine immerhin, jetzt haben wir eine Maus,
sage ich, ich kann mich nicht mehr anmelden.
Geil. Okay.
Power off.
Mal gucken, jetzt ist die Maus bestimmt wieder weg.
Nee, ich glaube,
das ist ein bisschen verbuggt.
Oh, wir haben eine Mauszeige wieder.
Jetzt funzt es auch.
Jetzt ist die Mauszeige wieder weg.
Der Mauszeiger verschwindet unter Bungie.
Ja gut, Chat.
Dann können wir das nicht ausprobieren.
Keine Chance.
Ohne Mauszeiger findest du es nicht.
Dann würde ich sagen, das nächste.
Also Cinnamon, ganz ehrlich,
Cinnamon können wir uns sparen. Das haben wir uns mit Mint
so oft angeguckt, Mate und Cinnamon.
Mal lieber ein paar ausgefallenere
Dinger ausprobieren.
Open Box, komm Leute, Open Box.
Auf geht's.
Volle Ladung.
Vielleicht mal eins für die ältere Generation, was meinst du?
Was meinst du damit? XFCE oder sowas?
also ganz im ernst als default system nehmen einfach kde also ich behaupte mal
dass windows user auf das 95 prozent der windows user mit kde in den default
settings ganz gut klar kommen nehmen einfach hier kd
Im KD beste ist KD und Gnome nicht eines der älteren doch
dass das waren die ersten zwei großen desktops unter Linux
ich weiß gar nicht was älter ist KDE oder Gnome
zumindest hat KDE Wobbly Windows und Wobbly Windows ist halt sehr pock
elementary elementary und war doch auch irgendein gtk ding oder in den knopfen gebastelt
aber kd ist
nice
also da kann man echt nichts sagen ich bin mittlerweile richter kde enjoyer
geworden
guck mal ich benutze das ja im prinzip genauso wie man teiling window manager
erster desktop browser im fullscreen zweiter desktop terminal in fullscreen dritter das
vierter desktop in dem fall chatarino dritter desktop ja dritter desktop dann halt idee und
und terminal oder sowas tag oder so kann man das kann man das nicht nach unten teilen vielleicht
So teilen.
Was ist denn, wenn ich nach unten teilen will?
Das geht nicht, oder?
Oh.
Geht doch.
Poggers Tiling.
Ja.
Guck hier, Terminal am Start.
Aski-Aquarium.
Und oben IDE-Stell.
du passt also einzig dumme ist dass man das def port immer noch richtig drauf funktioniert
ich habe keine ahnung was die historie angeht davon so und im prinzip genau so war das auf
meinem teiling window manager auch so und wozu brauche ich jetzt ein teiling window manager
wenn ich einfach kde verwenden kann genau das gleiche haben habe plus mehr irgendwelche floating
Windows da drüber gehen auch.
Doch, das stimmt.
Naja, so Sachen wie E3 sind schon ein bisschen leichtgewichtiger.
Dafür haben sie halt auch weniger Funktionen.
Ich sag nur...
Wobbly Windows.
Aber man muss aber auch mal sagen,
von wegen Leichtgewicht,
die Kiste ist jetzt
wirklich nicht die krasseste
von der Ausstattung her.
Hat 8GB,
einen halbwegs guten Ryzen und eine Mobile GPU.
Also das ist jetzt von der Hardware wirklich nichts Weltbewegendes.
Und KDE flutscht hier wie eine Eins drauf.
Wann gehst du komplett auf Linux? Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Warum soll ich komplett auf Linux gehen, wenn ich das so machen kann wie jetzt,
dass ich Linux und Windows einfach parallel verwende und die Betriebssysteme so verwende, wo ihre Stärken liegen.
Ich meine, ich wäre der Erste, der auf komplett Linux gehen würde, wenn alles ohne Probleme tun würde.
Ja, zum Beispiel Spiele mit Anti-Cheat.
Neue Spiele, dass ich mir sicher sein kann, dass sie laufen.
Video-Editing-Stellung.
Wobei, Video-Editing-Stellung.
Ich habe mir letztens mal ein bisschen DaVinci Resolve angeguckt.
Habe absolut abgeschissen mit Tastatur-Shortcuts.
Aber ich glaube, das ist die, das ist the way.
Mein Arbeitsrechner hat Windows.
Oh ja, leider.
Wobei ich es beim Arbeitsrechner so mache, ich logge mich ein, ich starte einen Fullscreen-Terminal. Fertig.
Seit wann gibt es mal geile deutsche Streams? Du musst followen, da bist du immer am Start hier.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Achso, hat er Kramer nicht installiert?
Der sieht ja schon wieder so hässlich aus.
Was ist denn das?
Warum hat man da kein Hintergrundbild?
Hast du schon?
Excellent.
High IQ.
Chat.
Ich fürchte, Openbox hat so ein paar kleine Probleme.
an die open box open box ist open box
ok chat power auf das packt das packt 100 pro wegen der vm rum ich wette mit euch das liegt
danach das liegt wieder hier an dieser das ist so krass verbaut das ist seit vor immer
Workstation 25.
Ist das kaputt?
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, warum.
Davor ging es perfekt.
Kein Hintergrund oder sonst was?
Okay, das ist aber ein
richtig krass minimalistisches
Openbox-Setup.
Ganz ehrlich, das Vorschau-Bild hat er deutlich mehr versprochen, als wie es jetzt eingerichtet ist.
Das ist ein super minimalistisches Openbox-Setup.
Ja, es wurden uns Anime-Grill-Hintergründe versprochen.
Wobei, das können wir abhelfen.
anime girls holding programming books
so was denn hier c++
Save Image as Desktop Downloads.
Okay, so und jetzt müssen wir gucken, wie macht man den Openbox.
Also Openbox ist noch genauso, wie ich das in Erinnerung habe.
Es ist halt super minimalistisch.
Du hast keine Leiste und nichts.
Das einzige, was du hast, wenn du auf den Desktop klickst, so ein Startmenü.
Okay, der Openbox-Configuration-Manager ist anscheinend nicht installiert.
Das ist sehr lightweight
Terminals
Genau im Terminal
Ja, sag mal
X-Terminal
WTF, da ist ja gar nichts installiert
Irgendein Terminal muss ich doch starten können
Terminal is bloated
As fuck, wer braucht schon Terminals
Okay, wie kriege ich denn jetzt eine Shell
Pass auf, Trick 17
wir machen okay habe ich konsole noch nicht ausprobiert das ist doch verpackt
oder die haben bestimmt die config vergessen da ist ja da ist ja nichts
drauf firefox ist zumindest drauf und auch nicht
ok dann wird schon jetzt mal rüber sollte ich nicht eigentlich ins terminal
kommt doch jetzt
pacman minus es
das ist das ist bestimmt verbuggt oder
West Term.
Ach ne, ich brauch ja...
Okay, X Term.
Jetzt kommt der Klassiker, Leute.
X Term.
Da haben wir wenigstens was.
Äh.
Terminal.
X Term.
Bam!
Ja, der Klassiker schlechthin.
Open Box.
Okay, jetzt brauchen wir...
OB-Conf hieß das doch, oder?
Ach ne, OB-Conf QT.
Haha.
Theme.
Das klingt nach...
Ah, ja, ja.
Okay, Appearance.
Font, Window.
Move, Mouse, Desktop.
Also Hintergrundbild kann man anscheinend nicht einstellen.
Moment.
Open Box.
background image auto set von 2011 excellent excellent using nitrogen a ok
das kann man machen wie kann man installieren an jemand aber ich meine
das ist jetzt definitiv nicht weil ein sondern das noch xbox wie war das noch
background setzen
wie ging das noch mal
bg mit mir das okay und jetzt
krieg ich ja schon anfällig so downloads wunderbar chat immerhin haben wir jetzt für
die weeps unter uns eine runde anime girl hintergrund
So.
Jetzt haben wir auch ein ordentliches Terminal hier.
Also das ist halt sehr minimalistisch, ne?
Openbox.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe früher eine ganze Weile Openbox only verwendet.
Als Desktop hier.
Natürlich auch mit diesem Hintergrund.
Klar, ne? Sollte klar sein.
OB-Conf.
Wie kann man jetzt hier einstellen,
was im Startmenü drin ist?
Da bin ich zu
pepega für.
Anscheinend gar nicht mehr, ne?
ob box konflikt startmenu menus
woher das xml
Oh man
Ja
Das habe ich früher verwendet
Openbox
Ehrlich gesagt
In der heutigen Zeit
Würde ich das glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr unbedingt verwenden
Openbox-Conv.
Wayland Compositor
with a look and feel from
Openbox. Oh je, für Thema
schlimmer. Menu Maker.
Das brauchen wir.
CacheOS Open Box Settings.
Ich darf nicht mal mehr löschen in XTurma.
Dann installieren wir jetzt
7 und 8
Gibt es Tidings in Openbox?
Ne
Ach, deswegen war das so kaputt
Cache US Openbox Settings konnte nicht installiert werden
Deswegen ist der Openbox auch nicht vorkonfiguriert
Weil es
Weil es Nitro
Nitro Gen immer gibt
Ach so
Tja
Da würde ich sagen, Openbox ist nicht so nice unter CacheOS.
Guck, wenn ich hier CacheOS Openbox Settings installieren will.
Äh, geht nicht.
Okay, das ist natürlich dann unsinnig.
Jetzt macht er eine Config für Openbox.
Naja, also das ist wirklich für alle Leute,
die auf super minimalistisches Zeug stehen
und Floating Windows wollen,
weil Tiling kann Openbox nicht.
mit xml war jetzt nicht rum
leute und schuss ich habe es verwendet so 2007 rum bis frage mich 2007 bis 2009
oder so habe ich auf dem box verwendet aber jetzt muss das nicht mehr sein
also der ist heilig support box aber das ist ein
jahrszeitling ist using box
irgendwie ein bisschen nostalgie faktor openbox
aber lassen das war mit openbox
Wo ist jetzt Stepshot?
Zack
Wann bist du mit Linux auf Desktop angefangen?
Was?
Du meinst, was das erste Desktop-Linux-Werbe-Warsch installiert hat?
Ubuntu 6.04?
Oder so? Gab's das?
oder Ubuntu 5.04
oder irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie sowas, ja.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Ubuntu, lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Ubuntu.
Ach so, jetzt mache ich hier.
ist hier und was war das für eins das war mein erstes das war mein erstes
warty warthog das war mein erstes ubuntu und auch das erste das erste linux was
ich mit desktop und so wo ich schon wiederum desktop rum gebastelt habe ich
meine das stimmt nicht ganz ich hatte noch früh noch viel viel früher noch
viel viel viel früher das war 2001 oder so da hatte ich eine
Suse auf CDs. Das waren so blaue
CDs.
Suse Linux
hatte ich mir damals gekauft.
Das waren auch vier
blaue CDs.
Und damit
bin ich aber damals nicht warm geworden.
So richtig
angefangen
Linux zu benutzen, habe ich mit
Ubuntu 4.10.
Nee, nee, das waren
Suse, Linux, das waren blaue
CDs, das weiß ich noch.
Es gab rote
CDs, das war die Professional
Professional Version.
Das waren, glaube ich, so rote CDs.
Und dann gab es
noch irgendwie so eine Home Edition
oder sowas, oder wie das hieß.
Nee, nee, nee,
Editions.
das an blaue cds personal personal cd
ja da war es da war da war es hier so sah die aus
Aber damit bin ich nicht warm geworden
Und so richtig angefangen hab
Also ernsthaft Linux zu benutzen
War mit
Ubuntu Warty Warthog
Also sprich Ende 2004
Also benutze ich ernsthaft Linux schon seit 22 Jahren
So lange schon Leute
Kann man sich grad vorstellen
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
UK UI
What?
Was ist das?
Ist das Wayland oder
oder X?
UK UI GitHub
UK UI Desktop Environment.
Macht jetzt nicht so einen wahnsinnig beliebten Eindruck.
Na doch.
Macht jetzt nicht so einen wahnsinnig beliebten Eindruck, oder?
Oh, das ist China-Chinesen-Kram.
Traue ich mich, das aufzumachen?
Wo kommen wir denn raus jetzt?
monke ist ich traue mich nicht okay das ist das ist immer noch okay leute wir
installiert in china desktop da gab es doch noch eins wie hieß das denn deep in
deep in gab es doch auch noch das fand ich gar nicht so übel
Das fand ich gar nicht so übel.
Okay, komm.
Ich bin das jetzt einfach aus.
UK UI.
Ah, wieder das übliche.
Next.
Install.
Das ist die Distro,
die die Regierung in China verwendet.
Aha, was ihr alles wisst, Chat.
High IQ Chat.
Die Subs haben sich gelohnt.
Mal gucken, dass ich nicht irgendwas vergessen habe.
wieder creator dashboard
übrigens weder stream gefällt kann ja der stelle ein bisschen kleinen set out
machen werden wir auf die installation von cash us warten
wir haben geschrieben gefällt er kann mir gerne auch ein follow da lassen dann
das sei das nächste mal wieder direkt mit am start und außerdem gibt es pro
Follow einen halben IQ-Punkt für den Chat.
Sub gibt einen ganzen.
Oder je nach Sub auch mehr.
Aber ich freue mich natürlich auch über Follows.
Immer wenn die Pfeile hochgehen,
ist das motivierend.
Ey, das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich. E17 oder so heißt das doch.
Das habe ich auch mal früher verwendet.
Mal kurz. E17 Desktop.
Das ist ganz abgedrehtes Ding.
Ja, Alignment.
Das ist auch sowas ganz Abgedrehtes.
Kann man Deep in ruhigen Gewissens nutzen?
Ich würde es nicht benutzen.
der prime sub geht nur am desktop weil die sonst für app store sachen bezahlen müssten
das ist richtig hängen geblieben das in app store policies also guck mal wenn ihr denkt
sieht hässlich aus habt ihr irgendwie recht ja aber enlightenment ist so auch so ganz spezielles
dinge warum man das verwenden sollte ich habe keinen plassen schimmer leute wirklich nett
der termin emulator ist aber ganz gut gewesen war eine zeit lang aber warum
man es verwenden soll ich weiß es nicht ich kann es mir also ich habe wirklich keine ahnung
enlightenment
sind die sind die eigentlich auch auf github nee oder bestimmt nicht
Moment, die haben eine C-Sharp
What the fuck
Die haben eine C-Sharp
GUI Toolkit, nur für ihren
Desktop, jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen
Contribute, wo ist denn der Source Code?
Wo findet man den hier denn?
Ah, hier
Die haben natürlich ein eigenes, gehostetes Skit
Okay, die sind mir schon mal sympathisch
Der hat seine
Der hat seine Katz hier einfach auf dem
Auf dem Startbildschirm
excellent rage was audio video play also enlightenment ist auch so was ganz
abgedrehtes wieder es wird aber immer noch weiterentwickeln
doch guck mal was cash ios macht ries da was hat ich jetzt ausgewählt
den China-Chinesen-Desktop.
Du bist wieder in Deutschland.
Keine Katzis mehr. Ja, Sätge.
Aber wahrscheinlich
findest du es auch an sich nicht schlecht, wieder da zu sein.
Aber wenn wir noch
Katzis an jeder Ecke hätten, wäre noch besser.
Alter, wie sieht denn das aus?
WTF?
Da komme ich mir ja vor, wie im Jahr
2005,
wie bei Ubuntu.
4.10 komme ich mir da vor.
Das ist X.
Das ist ein X.
Da drunter.
Ähm...
Warum zum Teufel sollte man sowas denn verwenden?
WTF?
Ich verstehe den Sinn davon irgendwie null.
Übrigens, es gibt noch nicht mal einen Apply-Knopf oder sowas.
warum warum gibt es das okay
den sinn verstehe ich absolut auf ich habe mich verdrückt ja ja sorry
die 3d beschleunigung noch aus oder backt ist deswegen wiederum das ist noch an deswegen
backt das rum glaube ich weil hier ist das terminal fass dann richtig also open vm tools
ja das packt open vm tools sind installiert
ich muss ganz schnell hier das muss die grafikkarte muss wieder ausgeschaltet werden
aber dass das kannst ja verknicken also dass das das sieht ja jetzt schon so amateurhaft aus dieses
ding und gefrickelt dass ich da beim besten willen nicht vorstellen kann dass
es wirklich jemand gibt er das benutzt
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Okay.
Set Background.
Ich würde ja gerne
ein Background setten, ne?
Ich würde gerne ein Background setten, aber
Man kann ja zwar hier Set Background auswählen,
aber man kommt nirgendwo hin, wo man den Background
setten kann.
Ist das kaputt, Alter.
Ach, hier kann man den Background setten.
Nice.
Äh.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie von Windows geklaut,
aber ist es, glaube ich, nicht.
Ich habe, ich habe wirklich, ich habe
Absolut keinen blassen Schimmer.
Warum das jemand verwenden sollte?
Okay, es hat ein Explorer-Icon,
was aussieht wie ein bisschen von Windows, ja?
Und wisst ihr, was das Schlimme
daran ist?
Dass das einheitlicher aussieht
als Windows selbst.
Das sieht besser
eigentlich aus als windows selbst aber ansonsten ist das was auch immer hier gerade abgeht
also ich habe wirklich habe echt keine ahnung warum man das benutzen soll das leuchte überhaupt
nicht ein weißes person kann sogar dark theme auswählen ok cursor theme das finde ich schon
mal ganz gut man kann es aber aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht aktivieren und ich muss bestimmt
und Reloggen dafür.
Das sieht ja wirklich aus.
Alter, das...
Oh, jetzt habe ich Backup ange...
Okay, es macht auch nichts.
Ich habe auf Backup gedrückt, aber es passiert natürlich
nichts, ganz klar.
Ey, warum sollte ich das denn benutzen?
By the way, about XFCE.
Ist das ein XFCE-Fork oder was?
Anscheinend.
Ey.
Meint ihr, Chat, meint ihr wirklich, es gibt Leute, die das benutzen und irgendwie feiern oder so?
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Nee.
Glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Irgendwer hat es ja gemacht.
Die China-Chinesen machen viel Zeug, wo man sich manchmal fragt, warum.
Redshift, das funktioniert nicht in der VM.
Es sieht halt wirklich sehr ähnlich zu Windows aus, das muss man ja mal sagen.
Aber es ist anscheinend
Irgendein XFCE
Aufsatz
Aber jemand der sowas
Achso meinst du das jemand der schon immer
Aber so lange gibt es das doch noch gar nicht
Ich check's nicht
Es ist ja gar nicht broken
Es funktioniert doch
also was jetzt ein bisschen rumgepackt hat ist hier set background und man
eigentlich hier auf personalize gehen muss
background theme font screensafe
Ich weiß nicht
Okay, Text Editor gibt es auch nicht
Was haben wir denn hier?
Haben wir hier irgendwas?
All
Was ist das?
A
Achso
Ah, Firefox haben wir drauf
Die übliche
Standard-Cache-US-Geschichte
Es ist ja eine
wilde Mischung hier
Island System Monitor
Es ist ja eine
wilde Mischung aus allem hier
Mate Terminal
XFCE Terminal
Die haben ja hier alles drauf, ne?
Alex Appearance
Knoll Control Center
Mates System Mates Sache das ist das ist eine ganz abgedrehte Mischung
Xfce
Abgedrehtes Zeug.
Der China-Chinesen-Desktop, Leute.
Plugins.
Notes.
Ui.
Digi-Notes.
na dann dieses komische komischen button haben sauer clip ort okay ich kann die
sachen ins clip hat man hat ein clip manager sich das richtig tatsächlich
klipper das finde ich wiederum nicht schlecht dass das da integriert ist aber
ohne mist diese dieser komische xxfc auf aufsatz der der ist mehr aus einem guss
als windows wir haben jetzt voll access zu all dein system ok f grip
weil sie haben schon geschafft aus der vm auszubrechen ja schnell machen
Die sind schon in meinem Micro-Con.
Oh, fuck. Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Dann wissen die, wann meine Tonne geleert wird.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
LX QT.
Made.
Also LX QT...
Ey, das sieht schon so billig aus, wenn ich das hier mir angucke.
LXDE ist das ganz alte.
Und LXQT?
Okay, komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir installieren das jetzt einfach.
Das ist bestimmt auch wieder nicht richtig vorkonfiguriert.
Ups, äh.
Oh, geh weg.
Ja, also
Patrick, du
bist ja anscheinend auch öfters in diesem Forum.
Hast du eine gute Idee,
was man dort so als
Ragebait-Thread aufmachen könnte?
Ich würde gerne
mal den ultimativen
Ragebait-Post machen auf
Mikrocontroller, im Mikrocontroller-
Forum.
Halt absichtlich
Fachbegriffe falsch verwenden,
irgendwelche Sachen
in C++ verwechseln und so.
So, wo die richtig heftig drauf anspringen.
Aber es darf halt nicht
zu obvious sein.
Und es muss auf jeden Fall so geschrieben
sein, dass ich selbst voll überzeugt
von mir, dass es stimmt, was ich sag.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wisst ihr, das ist eine gute Idee.
So, ich bin...
Alter, ein Thread.
einen Thread machen.
Ich bin jetzt einer von euch
und will vom Raspberry Pi posten.
Das würde, glaube ich, auch für sehr viele
antworten sollen. Wir haben sogar schon mal
KI gefragt.
Die Sachen waren nicht gut.
Ja, es gibt diesen, wie heißt der?
2040 oder so.
2040 oder irgendwie sowas.
Der Raspberry Pi Zero.
Ja.
Aber da müsste man halt
da müsste man halt wirklich so einen fetten Raspberry Pi
posten und sagen, ich bin jetzt einer von euch.
Habt ihr gute Ideen für ein
erstes Projekt? Ich bin jetzt endlich
auch
beim Mikrocontroller angekommen.
Und dann ein Bild vom normalen
Raspberry Pi posten.
Das würde Hard Rage beten, oder?
Nass auf dem Raspberry Pi, ja nass auf dem Raspberry Pi
Aber nicht im Mikrocontroller-Forum
Ne, das ist zu offensichtlich
Das ist zu offensichtlich
wie gesagt, sowas in die Richtung,
wie ich eben gesagt habe, so einen normalen
Raspberry Pi posten und sagen,
ich bin jetzt einer von euch,
hab auch meinen ersten Mikrocontroller gekauft
heute, Bild drunter vom Raspberry Pi
und dann fragen,
was wäre denn eurer Meinung nach ein erstes
gutes Projekt oder sowas?
Leute, da bannt doch keiner
was in diesem Forum.
In diesem Forum sind die größten
Vollspasten unterwegs. Da wird
nichts gebannt.
Wenn da
gebannt werden würde,
müssten wahrscheinlich locker die Hälfte der Leute
gebannt werden.
So.
Restart now und dann.
Okay, was haben wir jetzt?
LXQT
kommt jetzt. Okay.
Was ich immer ganz schrecklich in diesen Threads finde ist, wenn sie sich immer so an Kleinigkeiten gegenseitig korrigieren müssen.
Oder so auf, ich bin doch viel schlauer wie du machen.
So, so was weiß ich, irgendeiner postet, ähm.
Okay, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß was es ist, okay.
Irgendeiner postet hier
Include
Include und dann diesen
Blubpunkt, diesen
C++ Style, ja
Und da kommt dann der nächste an
Und sagt dann, hihi
Wie wärs mit
Anführungszeichen und sowas
Boah, Alter
Genau, oder so im Scheiß, ja
Das ist ja voll oversized.
Zu meiner Zeit hat man das auch mit Lochkarten gemacht.
Moin Michael, Fuffenspieljahren.
Das sieht ja genauso hässlich aus wie das andere.
Chad, was ist da los?
und es laggt.
No battery.
Ja, mach Witz.
Ich würde gerne die Auflösung
einstellen, wenn das...
Ah, okay, jetzt.
Also für einen minimalen Desktop
Das ist ja wirklich für
Low-End-Minimal-Systeme
gedacht und so
Ah ja
Dafür geht es wahrscheinlich klar
Es sieht halt wirklich aus wie
1990 oder so
Ist das so?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die streamen
LXQT-Settings
Kann man das aufmachen?
Monitor?
Shortcuts?
Kann man Cursor oder so einstellen?
Okay, das ist wirklich nur für sehr minimalistisch liebende Leute.
LXQT.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie, man hat noch einen Pentium 2 450
und möchte da unbedingt Linux drauf installieren.
Michael, 5 Spielejahren,
irgendwie glaube ich dir, dass du sogar auf Anhieb,
dass du koreanische Dance-Streams guckst.
Dippox, hast du eine KI gefragt,
sowas zu generieren,
so Rage-Bait-Dinger?
Das haben wir schon mal gemacht,
da kommt nichts Gutes bei raus.
Hyper Subscriber?
Ja.
Excellent Hyper Subscriber.
Ne, Hyper Subscriber.
Moment, wo ist denn mein Hyper Subscriber?
Hier.
Excellent Subscriptions.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, ich glaube, hier gibt es wirklich nicht mehr angucken.
Das ist für absolut minimalistische Leute hier unterwegs.
Die sehr minimalistisch unterwegs sind.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal was.
Wenn wir... Chat, Chat, Chat.
Jetzt, wo wir gerade bei minimalistischen Sachen sind.
Q-Terminal gibt es jetzt.
Die haben ein eigenes Terminal.
Okay, warum auch immer.
Und es sieht oldschool as fuck aus.
Leute, das...
Das Terminal resized sich nicht mal mehr.
Richtig.
wenn man es resized.
Und die Enter-Taste funktioniert nicht.
Na, das funktioniert ja alles perfekt.
Äh, sudo pacman-s
Also das ist ja wirklich nur für
enorm minimalistisch
liebende Leute.
Äh, warte mal.
Wir gucken jetzt hier, hier, hier, Eis-WM.
Gibt's das?
Ups.
Gibt's.
Passt mal auf.
Jetzt kommt es hier.
Ice WM.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob dieser komische Login-Manager das überhaupt starten kann.
Du hast es eben verpasst.
Eben hatten wir einen schönen Anime-Girl-Background.
Für den letzten Desktop.
Ganz knapp verpasst.
So, Ice WM Session.
Pass mal auf hier.
Jetzt kommt es hier.
Bäm, Leute, der hier
sagt Hallo
Ist das nicht top?
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch der schnellste Desktop, den ihr euch
vorstellen könnt
Wieso? Mal witzig, ich weiß das
nicht
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab den früher tatsächlich
ich mal auf so einem aufnehmen das auch das war tatsächlich ein pentium 2400 habe ich den
mal drauf installiert 2000 keine ahnung vier oder so
alex image qt ich habe jetzt was sie paint oder so
Graphics
Screen Crap
Nein, das ist nicht LXDE, das ist IceWM
Das wäre was für Kid Vogue, um die Scanner drauflaufen zu lassen
Ja, das wäre geil
Das wäre wirklich geil
Die indischen Scammer auf IceWM, Alter
Ja.
Das ist die Idee.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit
da nicht mehr geguckt, aber das würde wirklich gut passen.
Baka Player.
Oh.
Ähm...
Ganz wichtig.
Naja, es sieht halt ein bisschen aus wie Windows 98, ne?
Das Ding ist halt so, diese super minimalistischen Desktop-Manager und so.
Ja, die sind nicht bloated.
Das Problem ist nur, sobald du anfängst, einen Browser zu starten, geht der Bloat halt los.
Weil ein aktueller Browser braucht halt einen halbwegs aktuellen Rechner.
Du kannst, du kannst ein Firefox, du kannst wahrscheinlich ein Firefox starten auf einem Pentium 2 450.
So, dauert dann wahrscheinlich so eine Minute, bis der gestartet ist oder so.
Aber du kannst damit halt nichts machen.
Jede Webseite dauert ewig zum Aufrufen.
Ich meine, die Durchschnitts-Webseite lädt irgendwie heutzutage, was weiß ich, 16 MB JavaScript nach.
Deutsche Otto Lahn, ey.
Wer hätte gedacht,
dass wir uns mal
Max FPS angucken
unter Eis WM.
Ah gut, krieg ich wenigstens ein paar Cent.
Warum sprüht er sich den Kram an den Pobbes?
Achso, was ist mit dem denn los?
Und warum sprüht er sich das Zeug auf sein Ding?
Gut, ich meine, kann man machen, ob das jetzt so sinnvoll ist, weiß ich jetzt aber nicht.
YouTube kannst du vergessen, Alter.
Ohne Premium oder Adblock.
Ja, ich habe ein paar Subscriber verloren seitdem, ich weiß.
Weil ich kein Video mehr gemacht habe.
Achso, als ich den Titel gelesen habe, habe ich schon gedacht, Xavier Naidoo ist zu Gast oder so.
Ich habe letztens ein lustiges Meme gesehen.
Da hat oben einer ein Foto gepostet aus dem Edeka-Regal, wo drauf stand Kindersalami.
Und unten drunter ein Bild von Xavier Naidoo, wo drüber stand, ich habe es euch doch gesagt.
Irgendwie fand ich das lustig.
Also
Kindersalami gibt es ja schon ganz lange
Das ist halt einfach Salami für Kinder
Office Viewer
So, also irgendwie ist gefühlt hier alles
Doppel- und Dreifach drin
haben wir eigentlich ein Terminal gehabt?
Toolbar, Webbrowser, ja.
Hast du schon mal Angebote für deinen YouTube-Channel bekommen, zwecks Verkauf?
Nicht, dass ich mich erinnern könnte.
Sag mal, haben wir hier kein Terminal?
Development? Audio?
Gibt kein Terminal. Terminal ist overrated, outdated,
G-baited.
X-Screensaver! Jawoll!
Endlich! Wollte ich schon seit Jahren
mal wieder sehen.
Also,
ich mach mal hier rückgängig, ne? Ich wollte euch einfach mal
zeigen, wie... Das Ding gibt's ja auch
schon ewig und es soll halt aussehen wie
Windows 95 und es sieht halt auch aus wie Windows 95.
So.
Revert. Jetzt machen wir mal wieder was
Gescheites.
Ne, das gibt's da nicht.
Jetzt machen wir mal wieder was
Gescheites.
Jetzt installieren wir mal Mate.
Das ist nämlich Gnome 2.
Das läuft bestimmt auch nicht unter Wayland, oder?
oder ist läuft cinnamon mittlerweile unter weiland ich weiß dass mit hat ganz
lange zeit gezögert und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das schon so ist
okay das ding hat noch nicht mal einen eiken hat nun ein eigen und kein bild die drei ist
schön voll konfiguriert q teil spwm das alles ja ich habe eigentlich hier auf box die konfigurierung
hofft wenn man war einer der erste unterweihend lief sicher linux mint hat immer noch glaube ich
hat hat immer noch mal gucken ob man das backt wiederum aller hat immer noch nur x linux mint
Wayland?
Installing Wayland und Linux Mint.
Rechne mit Wayland ab
Mint 23 in 2026.
Ehrlich gesagt
will ich jetzt eigentlich gar kein X-Zeug mehr ausprobieren.
Okay, also Chat, Chat,
jetzt mal ernsthaft, von all dem,
was wir ausprobiert haben, ne?
Es war doch alles
unusable außer KDE.
Okay, Cosmic.
Cosmic ging noch
irgendwo. Aber der Rest war
komplett unusable.
Also,
warum, warum,
also, von dem, was wir ausprobiert haben,
ich habe hier ich habe hier keine kein hyperland und niri und so ausprobiert die läuft auch nicht
richtig hier auf der kiste kann ich euch übrigens wenn ihr mir das nicht glauben ich zeige euch das
mal wenn sie den sommer als letztes niri aber das wird nicht richtig laufen weil das in der
vor allem nicht nicht nicht das tut mir vor allem nicht also kd würde ich sagen
gefolgt also rein von dem wie es mir gefallen hat ja vom polisher ist es
eindeutig kdm kno muss man sagen aber klar ist für mich halt nicht gescheit zu
benutzen das erste ist kdk de ist schnell polischt super konfigurierbar hat ganz
viel gedönst. Top.
Danach fand ich Cosmic nicht übel.
Ähm,
und Gnome für die Leute, die es halt geil
finden, die Sache exakt
so zu machen auf diesem einen Weg, den es gibt.
Und die bisschen
motion sick werden bei dem ständigen Reihen
rausgesume.
Ansonsten
wüsste ich jetzt
nicht. Also,
wir haben diesen Deepin Desktop
mal ausprobiert vor ein paar Jahren.
Den fand ich auch gar nicht so schlecht, nur dass ich halt sagen muss, ich will keine China-Chinesen-Distribution verwenden.
deswegen kann ich eigentlich nur sagen kde beste kde beste und wenn es x sein
soll wenn es noch x11 sein soll dann einfach die drei wm fertig aus
aber nachdem x11 immer weiter aus gefasst wird überall war glaube ich jetzt
für mich auch der beste zeitpunkt zum umsteigen auf kde ich bleibe jetzt auch
auf kde also ist nichts von dem was ich heute gesehen habe hat mich irgendwie
ansatzweise davon überzeugt, was anderes benutzen
zu wollen.
Bleibe ich bei KDE.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal, ob Niri in der VM
funktioniert, aber ich kann euch jetzt schon prophezeien,
wird es nicht.
Hat Hyperland
eigentlich immer noch Hyperchan
oder Hyperchan
als Maskottchen.
Hier, Hyper-Chan.
Was da?
Hyper-Chan?
Was?
Remove?
Remove Hyper-Chan
because it makes the Discord-User
very upset.
warum flippen die so aus
ipad schaden ist perfekt für die ganzen weeks im discord
restart dann okay ich brauche euch jetzt schon unter niri kann ich nicht mal ein terminal starten
ohne dass es breakt.
Das liegt aber nicht an Niri, das liegt eindeutig
an der VM, das kann ich euch sagen.
Tiling, Window Manager, Wayland und VM
zusammen in Kombination kannst du komplett vergessen.
Oh, wir haben ja noch eine Sache vergessen.
Ubuntu, ne, Ubuntu hat auch
mittlerweile Gnome, stimmt's?
Ich wollte nämlich sagen, Ubuntu hatte doch so einen eigenen Desktop.
Wie hieß denn das Ding nochmal? Unity! Unity hieß das doch, gell?
Monkeys, was passiert hier?
Welcome to Noctalia.
Okay.
Next
Select the wallpaper below
No wallpapers found
Sehr gut
Appearance
Are you
Tokyo Night
Beste
Next
Customize
Also ganz ehrlich, die Farben gefallen mir schon
Aber nicht, wir lassen es
Wir lassen es einfach mal default
Alter, was zum...
Egal, all done.
Ach, das da oben ist das.
Das da oben ist das für die...
Moment.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich will Fullscreen machen.
Wir haben schon mal Mauszeiger.
Oh, es gibt
Moment, Moment
Funktioniert tatsächlich
Terminals standardmäßig auf
Niri?
Omachi, ja, aber das
Oh, was hab ich
Chat, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Aha
Was?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ich hier überhaupt mache gerade
Wie zum
Was habe ich hier gemacht?
Zweiter Desktop, erster Desktop, zweiter Desktop.
Fullscreen, okay.
Die Programme gehen nebeneinander auf.
Ah.
Ach so.
Oh.
Na gut, ein Fenster größer.
Ach so.
Aber kann ich das hier unten irgendwie hin?
Ach so ist das.
Das ist auch mal ein interessanter Ansatz, muss ich sagen
Das ist tatsächlich mal ein interessanter Ansatz
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob mich das so voll überzeugt, aber...
Also so auf Anhieb?
Übrigens, der Hintergrund ist viel zu transparent eingestellt, ne?
Wie konfiguriert man denn bei Niri den Hintergrund?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich habe Niri in Niri gestartet jetzt.
Ich glaube, das ist keine so gute Idee, oder?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Kann ich Niri in Niri Niri starten?
Ich mache es mal lieber wieder aus.
Was haben wir hier oben?
Control Center.
Wired Connection.
Bluetooth Wallpaper Selector.
Hier gibt es keine
Selektors.
Mikrofon aus.
Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Keep awake. Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Session Menü.
Tu was. Settings.
Also ich muss sagen,
Ja, okay, das ist angenehmer
Das ist das Default
Naja
Also, ich glaube
Ein bisschen
Die müssen sich mal einen Designer holen
Wie gesagt, ich bin in sowas auch schlecht
Aber das sieht alles viel zu gestopft aus
Hier
Funktional ist es schon
Du kannst aber schon mal cool
1000 Sachen einstellen, das finde ich eigentlich schon mal ganz nice
Das ist nicht von Niri
Was ist das dann?
Was ist das hier?
Kann man nicht einstellen.
Das ist ein eigenes Manager.
Ja gut, das wird ja wahrscheinlich
in enger Zusammenarbeit mit Niri erstellt, oder?
Aber man kann zumindest schon mal viel einstellen.
Das finde ich prinzipiell
immer so rum besser als andersrum.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich finde das gar nicht so...
Ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt, was ich jetzt hier sehe.
Eigentlich finde ich das ganz cool.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob ich es wirklich
jetzt gleich benutzen könnte.
Ja.
Aber irgendwie...
Chat, das...
Das hat doch irgendwie was, oder?
Man müsste sich das natürlich noch ordentlich einrichten,
dass man das nicht so transparent macht.
Der Pepo-Hintergrund und alles.
Aber das ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Ich glaube, das ist das Innovativste,
was wir heute gesehen haben.
Und vor allem...
Und vor allem scheint es ganz gut zu funktionieren.
ja keine direkten bugs oder so wie kann man noch mehr desktops anlegen
ich würde gern noch ein desktop anlegen geht das noch
Das ist ja fast wie unter Windows 8.
keck wie keck keck wie keck keck wie
wisser
ich bin das eigentlich ganz cool wenn ich jetzt mal wüsste wie man hier noch mehrere desktops
konfiguriert oder ist es sind das er workspaces super 3
nee dann dann switch auf den zweiten desktop guckt der switch wenn ich der
Es switcht, egal was, ich drücke immer zwischen den zwei hin und her.
Super O.
Ah.
Äh.
Ey, das ist so ein Overview.
Ah.
Erst wenn auf dem Desktop was drauf ist,
macht er neuen auf.
Ne.
Der Standardmäßig, der Zweier,
der Zweier ist immer auf.
Das kann man, das kann man, ah, okay.
Das kann man bestimmt umstellen.
Guck, immer wenn hier was auf ist,
macht er den auf.
Ich find das ganz cool, ehrlich gesagt.
Niri.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist, glaube ich,
das Beste, was wir heute ausprobiert haben.
Erweitert sich der Desktop nicht automatisch?
Nee.
Der scrollt immer weiter.
Wir sind immer noch weiter auf dem ersten Desktop.
Wir haben jetzt nur 1000 Terminals auf.
Super Escape?
Passiert nichts.
Was sollte passieren bei Super Escape?
Du hast horizontal und vertikal.
Es stimmt.
Stimmt.
Wie mache ich denn eine neue Vertikale?
Neues vertikales Fenster auf.
Also dass es nach unten scrollt.
Ach, das ist...
Ach, das ist ein neuer Desktop dann.
Ach, so ist das gedacht.
Also, das hier ist horizontal nebeneinander.
Und ich scrolle runter.
Dann ist es ein neuer...
Ach, so.
Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay.
Jaja.
Und es läuft auch erstaunlich gut in HVM.
Und es läuft mit Wayland in HVM.
Das ist ja auch mal was.
Das könnte man ja sogar wirklich verwenden.
Das finde ich ganz nice.
Nee, ich bleib...
Also mein Mini-PC lasse ich auf KDE.
Aber das finde ich wirklich ganz cool.
Also es hat was.
Das hat echt was.
genau du kannst das ist tatsächlich weil man im teiling window manager ist ja der platz beschränkt
der teilt sich weil so den screen space und hier kannst du einfach sagen ey komm auch wenn ich ein
bisschen scrollen muss mach halt einfach noch mal ein paar mehr auf ich finde dass das ist
eine wirklich coole Idee.
Das ist eine echt coole Idee.
Das ist so eine Art
Tiling Window Manager mit Infinite Scroll, ja?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Es hat schon ein bisschen was von einem Tiling Window Manager.
Weil ein Tiling trifft es nicht ganz.
Aber auch hier von den Fenstern immer im Fullscreen und wie die angeordnet werden.
Ein Scrolling Manager, genau.
Das finde ich schon cool.
Das hat echt was.
Und was macht das?
Super T?
Ah, dann floaten sie jetzt.
Nee, oder was?
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht, Chat?
Jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht.
Ah, dann floaten sie.
Ah, auch cool.
Auch cool.
Da kann man sich quasi...
Ach, guck mal. Das bleibt dann immer gestickt vorne.
Wie bekommt man das Fenster zurück ins Tiling?
Wieder Windows T drücken.
Nice. Gefällt mir.
Power off. Bam.
Exzellent.
Find ich gut.
Also Niri hat mir echt gut gefallen.
Also dann sagen wir mal,
okay, das Beste, was wir uns heute angeguckt haben,
war echt Niri.
Kannst ja mal auf dein Mini-PC
Jetzt nicht, jetzt muss ich erstmal ganz dringend aufs Klo
Dann nochmal an die frische Luft
Nochmal an die frische Luft, ich war ja heute schon
Ach, das ist für KDE
Und
Dann sehen wir uns vielleicht
Ah ne, morgen ist wieder normal arbeiten, ne
Da schauen wir uns, wir sehen uns auf jeden Fall die nächsten Tage
Wenn ihr es nicht verpassen wollt, Leute
Wer noch nicht gefollowt hat, kann mir jetzt gerne ein Follow da lassen
Würde mich freuen
und dann sehen wir uns
im nächsten Stream, Leute. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
CU